HEARING AT SOME LEE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
NUMBER TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE
BUT WE CAN TAKE THE ROLE PLEASE.
MCCARTY HERE.
CHáVEZ.
MEDINA.
VOEPEL.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
OKAY TODAY WE HAVE A VARIETY
TOPICS FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO THE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE WILL START OFF WITH
THERE ARE. TWO ISSUES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE GE'S.
PLAYED TO APPRENTICESHIP AND
CERTIFIED NURSE.
SO ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
ALEJO'S GOING TO GO FIRST ON THE
SIDEWALK THROUGH THE BACK CLEAR.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA START FIRST
WITH THE LA A CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR PAUL STEINHAUSEN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE SERGEANT IS DISTRIBUTING A
HAND OUT TO YOU.
TITLED APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
AND THE HAND OUT PROVIDES
BACKGROUND AND INFORMATION.
NECESSARY TO UNDERSTAND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
ASSESSMENT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO PAGE ONE OF THE HANDOUT.
SHOWS THAT APPRENTICESHIP. WHICH
IS OFTEN CALLED THE BURNING
WHILE LEARNING MODEL.
.
INVOLVES SPONSORS
ARE THE SPONSORS ARE EMPLOYERS
AND TRADE UNIONS AND AND OTHERS
LABOR UNIONS.
AT THEY RECRUIT APPRENTICES IN
THE APPRENTICES ARE PAID WAGES
WHILE THEY TRAIN ON THE JOB.
AND AFTER BUSINESS HOURS.
THE APPRENTICES ATTEND CLASSES
S. CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION IT'S
KNOWN AS RELATED SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION OR RSI SUCH THEIR
CLASSROOM TIME.
AND TYPICALLY YOU FINDS
APPRENTICES IN BUILDING TRADES
IN PUBLIC SAFETY SUCH AS.
FIREFIGHTING RESEARCH INDICATES
THAT APPRENTICESHIP IS AN
EFFECTIVE MODEL. FOR OUR
TRAINING WORKERS.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS A GOAL TO
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF APPRENTICES
IN THE STATE BY TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN.
PAGE TWO YOU LOOK ON PAGE TWO.
OF THE HAND OUT. NOTES THAT THE
STATE HELPS TO SUBSIDIZE SOME OF
THE SPONSORS CLASSROOM.
COSTS
SO SOME OF THOSE RSI COSTS
THAT THAT THE APPRENTICES MUST
UNDER GO THAT STATE HELPS TO PAY
FOR SOME OF THAT A PORTION.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR THE STATE IS
PROVIDING FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR RSI NOW THROUGH CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM.
AND I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
STATE HAS A SECOND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM A NEW
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM POP
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. ARE A NET INITIATIVE
WHICH PROVIDES GRANTS AS SEED
MONEY.
TWO SPONSORS TO COMMUNICATE ALL
AGES AND SCHOOLS TO ESTABLISH.
NONTRADITIONAL APPRENTICESHIPS
WHAT'S BEEN TRADITIONALLY
NONTRADITIONAL WHICH IS IN THE
AREAS OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY.
AND AND AND SOME OTHER AREAS.
.
AS WELL HEALTH CARE IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE.
SO TO QUALIFY FOR THE STATE ARE
A SIGH FUNDING SO THAT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS SPONSORS HAVE TO
PARTNER WITH KATE TWELFTH WHICH
IS TYPICALLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND TYPICALLY WHAT YOU SEE IS
APPRENTICESHIPS.
REGISTER PROGRAMS HAVE THEIR OWN
STAND ALONE TRAINING CENTER NOT
IT BETWEEN THE COLLEGE HERE AT
SCHOOL IT'S AROUND STANDALONE
TRAIN CENTER THE TRADE THAT
LABOR UNION MIGHT RUN FOR
EXAMPLE.
AND THE SPONSORS EMPLOY THEIR
OWN INSTRUCTORS.
WHAT YOU SEE THEN IS?
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
INCOMMUNICADO EDGES WILL TAKE A
PORTION OF THE RSI THE CLASSROOM
COSTS
TO KIND OF. HAVE A GENERAL
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM.
AND THEN THE SPONSORS GET THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE RSI AGAIN TO
HELP SUBSIDIZE THE COST FOR FOR
CLASSROOM TRAINING.
PAGE THREE OF THE HANDOUT NOTES
THAT ABOUT NINETY PERCENT OF
APPRENTICESHIP CLASSES.
OUR AFFILIATE BETTER FOR
AFFILIATED WITH COMMUNICATIVE IS
OUR CREDIT KNOWN AS CREDIT WHICH
MEANS THAT THE COURSE UNITS CAN
APPLY TOWARD AN ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE. TYPICALLY IT'S ASIDE IS
ASSIGNED A SELECTIVE UNITS.
THE REMAINING TEN PERCENT OF
COMMITTEE COLLEGE AFFILIATED
COURSES AS WELL AS ALL SCHOOL
AFFILIATED.
A.
CLASSES ARE CONSIDERED NON
CREDIT OR NOT FOR CREDIT.
BUT WHETHER IT'S WHETHER IT'S
CREDIT FOR NOT CREDIT.
THE CONTENT IS IS SIMILAR
IT'S COMPARABLE I AND ALL OF THE
PROGRAM'S WHETHER NONCREDIT
CREDIT.
SCHOOL AFFILIATED RESULT IN
INDUSTRY CERTIFICATIONS
WHICH IS WHAT WORKERS NEED TO.
.
TO BE IN THEIR INDUSTRY AND AND
PRACTICE OUR TRADE ON A ON A
PERMANENT BASIS.
PAGE FOUR. OF THE HANDOUT NOTES
THAT WHETHER RSI IS OFFERED ON A
CREDIT OR NON CREDIT BASIS OR BY
SCHOOL OR BY COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
STATE FUNDS ARE A SIGH BASED ON
THE REGULAR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NINE CREDIT RATE.
AND IN THE CURRENT YEAR THAT
STATUTORY HOURLY RATE IS FIVE
DOLLARS NINETY CENTS WHICH
EQUATES TO ABOUT THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR A FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENT NFT .
IN RECENT YEARS THE AMOUNT OF
RSI HOURS THAT SPONSORS HAVE
PROVIDED TO APPRENTICES.
HAS EXCEEDED THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THE STATE HAS BUDGETED. FOR
RSI.
AND AS A RESULT PURSUANT TO
STATUTE THE STATE HAS MADE PRO
RATA REDUCTIONS.
AND THESE REDUCTIONS HAVE.
HAVE RESULTED IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS OR SO.
IN REDUCTION OF ABOUT ONE
PERCENT IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN. I AND ALL THE WAY UP TO
TWENTY FOUR PERCENT PRO RATA
REDUCTIONS IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
SO INSTEAD OF PROVIDING FIVE
DOLLARS NINETY CENTS PER STUDENT
PER CLASSROOM OUR THE STATE IS
PROVIDING AN AVERAGE ABOUT FOUR
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS TO THE
SPONSORS THIS YEAR.
NOW DESPITE THESE PRO RATA
REDUCTIONS OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS SPONSORS HAVE.
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY THE
NUMBER OF RSI HOURS THEY PROVIDE
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IN THE
FIGURE ON THE NEXT PAGE.
YOU CAN SEE THOSE HOURS CONTINUE
TO GROW.
AND THIS REALLY IS EVIDENCE OF.
THE VALUE SPONSORS PLACE ON
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PROVIDING NEEDED. A WORKERS
TRAIN WORKERS FOR THEIR
INDUSTRY.
SO PAGE SIX DESCRIBES THE
GOVERNOR'S THREE PROPOSALS ON
APPRENTICESHIP.
YOU SEE THE FIRST CHECK BOX ON
PAGE SIX THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME MONEY.
TO MAKE UP FOR THE PRO RATA
REDUCTIONS
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN AND. AND THE CURRENT
YEAR.
NOT PROPOSAL DOES NOT PLACE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF THESE
FUNDS.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR IS TO PROVIDE SEVENTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING. FOR OUR SI.
MOST OF THAT A. DOLLAR AMOUNT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH MORE ARE A SITE
FOR A MORE OUR SITE HOURS TO
FIND MORE HOURS. AND IT WOULD
BRING THE BUDGET YEAR HOURS UP
TO WHAT'S EXPECTED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR SO YOU WOULD YOU
WOULD FIND ABOUT JUST UNDER
UNDER NINE MILLION HOURS AGAIN
WHICH IS EXPECTED AND. IN THE
CURRENT YEAR INTO FUND THAT
AGAIN AND IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
THE REST OF THE MONEY THAT
ONGOING MONIES ASSOCIATE WITH
INCREASING THE RSI RATE.
TO SIX DOLLARS AND FORTY NINE
CENTS AGAIN FROM FIVE DOLLARS
NINETY CENTS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
STATUTORY RATE.
THERE'S A THIRD PROPOSAL HERE
THE GOVERNOR HAS.
AND THAT WOULD ALLOW SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE APPRENTICESHIP
COURSES TO GENERATE FUNDING AT A
MUCH HIGHER RATE TEN DOLLARS AND
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS.
PER HOUR WHICH WOULD WHICH IS
ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT HIGHER THAN
THE PROPOSED SIX DOLLARS FORTY
NINE CENT RSI RATE. SO AGAIN
THAT WOULD BE JUST ANA A CERTAIN
PORTION OF.
OF APPRENTICESHIP RSI OWE IT
WOULD GET THAT HIGHER RATE IN
THE FUNDING WOULD BE PAID OUT OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE GENERAL
PURPOSE POT OF MONEY SO THE OF
APPORTIONMENT.
I'D RATHER THAN THE
APPRENTICESHIP CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM.
TO EARN THE HIGHER FUNDING RATE
APPRENTICESHIP COURSES WOULD
HAVE TO BE TAUGHT BY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS
RATHER THAN.
SPONSORS INSTRUCTOR.
AND THE GOVERNOR INDICATES THAT
HIS PROPOSAL COULD INCENTIVIZE
MORE COLLEGES TO OFFER CREDIT
APPRENTICESHIPS.
SO PAGE SEVEN SUMMARIZES OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS THOSE THREE PROPOSALS.
WITH REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
FIRST PROPOSAL.
STATE LAW MAKES CLEAR THAT IF
STATE FUNDING IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO COVER ALL OF THE HOURS THAT
SPONSORS ARE PROVIDING SPONSORS
NEED TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO STAY
WITHIN THEIR ANNUAL BUDGET
ALLOCATION.
DESPITE KNOWING THAT STAMPER
STATE REIMBURSEMENT WAS LIKELY
TO BE PRO RATED DOWNWARD AFTER
ALL IT'S BEEN PRETTY DOWNWARD
EVERY YEAR FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. SPONSORS CONTINUE TO
COVER THESE COSTS AND THE
PROGRAM CONTINUED TO GROW
RAPIDLY SO EMPLOYERS FELT THAT
IT WAS WORTH IT THAT OUT TO KICK
IN THE EXTRA MONEY FOR THE
CLASSROOM HOURS.
SO AS A RESULT WE DON'T SEE A
COMPELLING REASON FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
RETROACTIVE REIMBURSEMENTS.
WITH REGARD TO THIS GOVERNOR
SECOND PROPOSAL.
WE WE HAD KNOWLEDGE SO THAT
WELL THOUGH PROVIDING
RETROACTIVE RSI HOURS MIGHT NOT
BE NECESSARY WE DO AGREE WITH
WITH THIS THAT THE STATE SHOULD
TRY TO AVOID. FUTURE PRO RATA
REDUCTIONS DO WHATEVER I CAN TO.
TO AVOID THOSE FUTURE REDUCTIONS
WE ARE CONCERNED A BIT THAT AS.
CURRENTLY PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR THE AUGMENTATION MAY
NOT BE ENOUGH THOUGH. ARE IN THE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO FULLY
ALIGN FUNDING WITH THE PROJECTED
HOURS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AS I AS I'VE DESCRIBED
ON ON PAGE SIX PREVIOUS PAGE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WOULD FIND THE
SAME NUMBER OF HOURS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AS IN AS WHAT'S
EXPECTED IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
AND GIVEN RECENT GROWTH TRENDS
SPONSORS LIKELY ARE GOING TO
EXCEED THAT SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
LEVEL. AND IF THEY DO. WE'RE
GONNA END UP IN THE SAME
POSITION WHERE YOU HAVE TO MAKE
A STATE TO HAVE TO MAKE ANOTHER
ROUND OF PRO RATA REDUCTIONS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR.
SO THE THIRD DIED.
CHECK BOX YOU.
WE WE REALLY KIND OF OUR SAXMAN
IS WE DON'T THINK THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING THE
CREDIT RATE FOR CERTAIN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CREDIT
APPRENTICESHIP COURSES IS
WARRANTED.
THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPRENTICESHIPS YET VIRTUALLY
ALL.
VIRTUALLY ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPRENTICESHIP COURSES ARE ARE
ARE ALREADY. OFFERED ON A CREDIT
BASIS.
AND GIVEN HOW QUICKLY
APPRENTICESHIPS HAVE BEEN
GROWING IN RECENT YEARS THE
STATE ALREADY IS ON TRACK TO
REACH A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND.
APPRENTICESHIPS BY TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN WHICH IS
THE GOAL OF THE STATE HAS SET.
OUR FOURTH THE KIND OF
ASSESSMENT IS THAT THE PROPOSAL
WOULD RESULT IN EVEN GREATER
INCONSISTENCY IN RULES UP FOR
SIMILAR APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THIS IS ALREADY
A COMPLEX
SYSTEM OF PAYMENT AND IT WOULD
REALLY FURTHER COMPLICATE
APPRENTICESHIPS BY PROVIDING A
HIGHER FUNDING RATE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER FUNNY RATE
FOR CERTAIN COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
RSI POWERS THOSE CREDIT HOURS
BUT NOT FOR OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE APPRENTICESHIP R. S.
HOURS ARE NOT FOR SCHOOLS EITHER
THE SCHOOLS WOULDN'T GET THAT
HIGHER RATE. AYE EVEN THOUGH ALL
OF THIS CONTENT IS COMPARABLE.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ON
PAGE EIGHT. THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS FIRST TO REJECT
THE RETROACTIVE REIMBURSEMENTS
SECOND TO APPROVE ACTUALLY MORE
THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING ON ON GOING BASIS TO
PROVE TWENTY THREE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS RATHER THAN
SEVENTEEN POINT EIGHT. MILLION
AND THAT WOULD FIND TEN PERCENT
GROWTH IN OUR ESSAY OFF RSI
HOURS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WHICH IS. THE AVERAGE
GROWTH OF THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND GOING FOR
FORWARD FOR LEGISLATURE.
.
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT THE NUMBER
OF HOURS THAT SPONSORS ARE
PROVIDING AND TRY TO MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS ANNUALLY TO AGAIN TO
AVOID MORE OF THESE PRO RATA
REDUCTIONS IN FUTURE YEARS.
THIRD RECOMMENDATION ITS REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO EARN THAT.
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER RATE FOR
CERTAIN CREDIT APPRENTICESHIP
COURSES.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
BERMAN A FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING CARE MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMONG THE
BECAUSE OF WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I APPRECIATE THE DETAILED
OVERVIEW THAT PAUL JUST PROVIDED
THE CABLE COMPREHENSION
COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF HOW
PARTNERSHIP. FUNDING WORKS IS
THAT IS A PRETTY COMPLICATED
ISSUE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
AN INCREASE OF FORTY EIGHT POINT
FOUR MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
OF THIS AMOUNT THIRTY POINT SIX
MILLION HAS PROVIDED ON A ONE
TIME BASIS TO FUND SHORTFALLS IN
RSI FUNDING. OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
WE ARE PROPOSING TO FIND THESE
PER YEAR SHORT FALLS IN OUR SIDE
REIMBURSEMENTS BECAUSE THE STATE
IS STATUTORILY EXPECTED TO PAY
FOR THE COST OF THE CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTIONAL COMPONENT. OF AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS AND
PROGRAM SPONSORS HAVE HAD TO
COVER THE COSTS OF THESE
UNFUNDED REIMBURSEMENTS.
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THIS
IS A GOOD USE OF AVAILABLE PROP
NINETY PROP NINETY EIGHT ONE
TIME REVENUES THIS YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION AND ON GOING
REIMBURSEMENTS. FOR PROGRAMS FOR
ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTIONAL POWERS
PROVIDED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. AT AN
INCREASED RSI HOURLY RATE OF SIX
DOLLARS AND FORTY NINE CENTS IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
CONSISTENT WITH THE PAST THREE
YEARS
THE BUDGET CONTINUES TO INCLUDE
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE. WHICH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF MINIATURE
ADMINISTERS THE RECOUP PETTED OF
GRANT PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE START
UP AND IMPLEMENTATION COSTS FOR
NEW AND INNOVATIVE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
EMERGING NONTRADITIONAL SECTORS.
AND FOR PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PROPOSING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO CLAIM REIMBURSEMENT
THROUGH THE COLLEGE CREDIT
APPORTIONMENT RATE. RATHER THAN
RSI RATE FOR ELIGIBLE
APPRENTICESHIP COURSES.
SPECIFICALLY ONLY FOUR CREDIT
COURSES TAUGHT BY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO BE AROUND REIMBURSED
AT THE HIGHER CREDIT
APPORTIONMENT OPTION.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS
REQUESTED THIS ALTERNATIVE
REIMBURSEMENT OPTION FOR SEVERAL
REASONS.
IT WILL ENCOURAGE MORE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO BE
CREATED IN THE STATE. THE
FEDERAL WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT OR WE GO ON
REQUIRES EACH STATE TO DEVELOP A
WORKFORCE PLAN AND CALIFORNIA'S
PLANT EXPECTS TO DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF TRAINED APPRENTICES BY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SEVEN.
WE WOULD EXPECT THAT SOME
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE GRANT RECIPIENTS.
WOULD COLLABORATE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SPONSORS AS THEY DEVELOP THEIR
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM CURRICULUM.
TO HAVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY MEMBERS TEACH THESE SOME
OF THESE COURSES THAT THEY COULD
CLAIM THE HIGHER RATE.
ALSO COMMUNITY COLLEGES OFFER A
WIDE VARIETY OF CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE TAUGHT BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAD
POINTED OUT THAT OUR PROPOSAL
WHERE ENCOURAGE COLLEGES TO SEEK
OUT A NEW APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
SPONSORED. TO CREATE AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THE PETE
WOULD BE ALIGNED WITH THAT
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY COLLEGES HAVE NO
INCENTIVE TO TRY TO BUILD IT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALIGNED WITH THEIR CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY'RE
REIMBURSED AT A MUCH LOWER RATE.
A PROPOSED APPORTIONMENT
REIMBURSEMENT OP SOON ALSO WAS
EXPECTED TO FREE UP SOME ARE S.
SITE FUNDING DEMAND.
COULD BE USED TO FUND PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS IN BOTH KATE TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE SPONSORED
PROGRAMS. THAT WOULD STILL CLAIM
THE RSI APPORTIONMENT. AND IT
WOULD PROVIDE OUR SITE
REIMBURSEMENTS TO NEW
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT ARE
STARTED UP THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE ONCE THEY'RE UP AND
RUNNING. FOR COURSES THAT ARE
NOT REIMBURSED BY THE
APPORTIONMENT CREDIT RIGHT.
ALSO BY ENCOURAGING COLLEGES TO
BEGIN MORE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS FOR WHICH THEY COULD
CLAIM THE APPORTIONMENT RATE.
WOULD HELP COLLEGES INCREASE
THEIR FTA ELSE AT A TIME WHEN
MANY COLLEGES ARE EXPERIENCING
DECLINING ENROLLMENTS.
WE WILL BE REVISING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN THE MAY
REVISION TO CLARIFY THAT
APPRENTICESHIP COURSE WORK THAT
IS REIMBURSED THROUGH THE
APPORTIONMENT PROCESS. WILL BE
BASED ON THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS PROVIDED TO.
APPRENTICES WHICH IS SIMILAR TO
THE PROCESS FOR THE RSI
REIMBURSEMENT.
IT SUMMARIZES OUR PROPOSAL AND
I'M HAPPY TO ENTER.
THANK YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY
KRISHNASWAMY OF RESTAURANTS
WHERE THE COMPANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS REPRESENT WHAT WE
THINK IS REASONABLE BUDGETING
PRACTICES. THOUGHT YOU KNOW AS
YOU HEARD THERE IS A ONE TIME
PROPOSAL WE THINK A.
TRUING UP RATES FOR.
THAT WE COMMITTED TO IN STATUTE
IS A REASONABLE WAY TO.
TO ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS WE
THINK IT'S AT A REASONABLE USE
OF THE THIRTY ONE MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDS.
FOR THE SECOND SET OF
ADJUSTMENTS THE EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO A BOTH REVISED THE
RATES AND TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF HOURS PER REMEMBER SAYING. WE
THINK THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH HOW
YOU ARE TYPICALLY BUDGET FOR
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NOT THAT ARE
DRIVEN BY ENROLLMENT CASELOAD
POPULATION.
WITH REGARD TO THE FINAL
TRAILER BILL CHANGED AUTHORIZED
COURSES IN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS TO RECEIVE THE CREDIT
RATE WE THINK THAT IT'S A.
REASONABLE BUDGET PRACTICE TO
FUND CREDIT COURSES AT THE SAME
RATE REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY'RE
TAUGHT AND SO WE THINK IT
ALLIANCE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
WITH HOW WE FIND OTHER CREDIT
INSTRUCTION IN OUR COLLEGES.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THOUGH THAT WE
ARE MAKING AS YOU ALL HAVE
DISCUSSED A PREVIOUS HEARINGS WE
ARE CONSIDERING. A BROADER
CHANGES TO OUR FUNDING FORMULA
IN OUR APARTMENT SYSTEM AND SO
WILL OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO CONSIDER.
HOW THIS PROPOSAL FITS INTO
THAT?
INTOBACK CONSTRUCT WHATEVER
CONSTRUCT LEGISLATURE'S.
AB ANSWER QUESTIONS.
I KNOW WE HAVE A PUBLIC.
COMMENTS
AT THE END THE END THEY HAVE AND
JUST FORGET ABOUT IT IN THE.
IN THE HOUSES TALKS ABOUT ONE
LETTER WE GOT FROM THERE.
FIREFIGHTERS IT TALKED ABOUT HIS
NEW A PORSCHE APPORTIONMENT
FUNDING.
WILL BE DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
HOW THEY STRUCTURE THEIR THEIR
THEIR PROGRAMS AND THE
TRADITIONALLY RELY ON THE OLD
SYSTEM ARE SIZE SO YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ABOUT THAT. I THINK THIS
IS THE ISSUE THE THE PUBLIC
FINANCE RAISED AROUND YOU KNOW
THEIR COMMITMENT IN THE MAY
REVISION TO FUND IT BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF HOURS ME FOR THE SAME
CONCERNS AND WE'RE HAPPY TO AND
I THINK WE. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
OKAY.
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM.
VOEPEL.
JUST A COMMENT.
.
ON THE ISSUE OF.
PROVIDING ONE SIZE FITS ALL
FUNDING CERTAIN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS FOR
THEIR DISTRICTS FOR THEIR AREA
IN SAN DIEGO.
WERE OF A MARITIME OUR AREA AND
WE NEED WELDERS HIGH TECHNOLOGY
ELECTRICITY AND STRINGING
HUNDRED SOME MILES OF FIBER
OPTIC CABLE SO IT'S NOT JUST A
REGULAR ELECTRICITY NEED
ADVANCED TRAINING SHIP FETTERS.
ON AND ON SO. WE DEFINITELY.
CAN NOT HAVE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
AND.
AS FAR AS THE FUNDING GOES WHO
WE SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SEND THE MONEY TO THE HIGHEST
USE POSSIBLE IN WHICH CASE I CAN
UNDERSTAND ON THE. ACCOUNTING
PEOPLE WANTED TO HAVE LIKE A A
FLAT RATE FOR EVERYONE IN EASILY
ACCOUNTED FOR.
BUT.
IT THE END OF THE DAY BEAN
COUNTERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO COUNT
DIFFERENT SIZE BEINGS.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S YOUR JOB WITH.
THANK YOU FOR THE PROPER
PRESENTATION FOR THE. APARTMENT
OF.
.
FINANCE.
SQUASH
QUESTION THE GODFATHER PART IS
WHITE OKAY.
FROM MY YOUR YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THE.
SYSTEM WORKING
THE COURT SYSTEM WE HAVE
WORKING.
I WOULD SAY IT'S WORKING REALLY
WELL BUT I MEAN THE NUMBER OF
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
GROWING.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO TRY
TO REIMBURSE PROGRAMS FOREST
PAUL MENTIONED PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN UNDERFUNDED FOR YEARS BUT
THEY'VE CONTINUED.
TO EXPAND THEIR PROGRAM SO
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY GETTING
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING THEN THE
APPRENTICES ARE NEEDED.
WE JUST FEEL THAT THE STATE
SHOULD BE KIND OF MAKING GOOD ON
ITS COMMITMENT TO FUND THESE
INSTRUCTIONAL COSTS.
THANK YOU FROM.
FROM.
.
CHRISTIAN.
THANK YOU MANY COLLEGE AS YOUR
OFFICE.
WHEN YOU ESTABLISH A CRITERIA
FOR THE CERTIFICATES.
OR THE DEGREES WHO ESTABLISHES
THE CRITERIA.
I AM GOING TO OF ART IN GENERAL
OR IN.
WITH REGARD TO APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT I THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WE ARE CROSSING
GUARD TO APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE THE STUDY.
CERTIFICATE FOR A ISSUE A SHIP
BUILDER ELECTRICIAN.
OR.
WHO ESTABLISHES THAT CRITERIA
FOR DISC?
I'M GONNA DEFERRED IN MY
COLLEAGUE COPIER AMERO BICU.
WHO WERE STRUGGLING MUSICIANS
HAVE A MAN IN SACRAMENTO MEDINA
AND
JUST OFFICE
THANK YOU? ARM.
IF IT'S AN APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAM THERE'S A
SPONSOR. THAT'S THAT'S AN
EMPLOYER. THAT WILL DETERMINE
THE STANDARDS THAT WILL THEN BE
APPROVED BY THE VISION APPENDAGE
OF STANDARDS.
SO IT WOULD BE THE INDUSTRY WILL
BE DRIVING.
THE STANDARDS OF ANY
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING PROGRAM.
SO I THOUGHT AND SO THE.
THE ISSUE ABOUT HAVE BEEN.
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF UP
FACULTY TEACH.
IS A. IS THIS UNIQUE TO THE
FACULTY I MEAN TO THE.
COMMITTEE COLLEGES OURS AND ADDS
ON TO THE SURPRISE PROGRAM THIS
THAT WAS BY THE INDUSTRY OR.
WHATEVER CLASSES OF THE TEACHING
WELL ARE I'M THINK WHO AND
REFERENCE TO LIKE IF THE
INCREASE IN THE RATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. FOR CREDIBLE
AND COURSES IS WE HAVE TODAY
EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT WE THINK COULD BE LEVERAGE
TO DEVELOP IN A PATCH OF
TRAINING PROGRAM.
SO WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT.
AND.
AN EXISTING PROGRAM BE IT IN
WELDING.
FOR EXAMPLE THAT THAT WOULD
FORCE THAT INSTRUCTION IN THAT
CURRICULUM.
TO BE RECONCILED WITH THAT
EMPLOYER AND WHICH THEN THEY
WOULD AGREE ON. YOU KNOW HOW
THAT CURRICULUM BEST CONCEPTS A
STANDARD SO.
SO WE THINK THAT THAT WOULD.
ACTUALLY HELP IN THE LINING.
COURSES AND PROGRAMS WITH
INDUSTRY NEEDS AND AN ARM.
AND OUT IN PRECARIOUS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
LATER ON AND HEARING TODAY ABOUT
CG  AND I THINK. IN THE SIX
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE THERE'S
BEEN THIS WHOLE. DISCUSSION
ABOUT MOVING.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND HIGH
SCHOOLS IN THE RELEVANCY OF
EDUCATION AND JOBS.
AND I THINK WE'RE SEEING A LOT
TO GET THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED.
MY THE PARTNER FINANCES A YOU
KNOW THE PROGRAM IS WORKING
WELL.
IT EYES I LOOK AT IT BECAUSE
WE'VE ALSO BEEN WE'VE
UNDERFUNDED COMMUNICABLE JUST
QUITE A BIT IN THE.
WHY AGREE WITH THE LA JOH NA WHY
SHOULD WE RETROACTIVELY THREE
FUNDED THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO MEET
IT BECAUSE OF THE? BUSINESS
COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE SO.
MY POSITION IS I WOULD PROBABLY
YOU.
REJECT THAT ELEMENT STRICTLY
BECAUSE I'M TRYING HEALTH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE.
BUT I ALSO AGREE WITH THE LA
OWES RECOMMENDATION THAT WE.
DO THE TWENTY THREE POINT SIX
MILLION ONGOING AUGMENTATION.
DEFINE THE ANTICIPATED OUR SIDE
HOURS IS I THINK HE'S EXACTLY
RIGHT WE. THIS IS A GROWING AREA
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO THIS I
THINK THAT'S A VERY SMART
RECOMMENDATION BY THE LA THOUGH.
AND.
.
AND AS FAR AS THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INSIGNIFICANT HIGHER RATES.
FOR CREDIT PRESENTATION JUST AS
DISCUSSED HERE.
THE CRITERIA ESTABLISHED BY THE
INDUSTRIES
AND.
.
SO I DON'T SEE WHY WE'RE DOING
THAT SO.
.
I WOULD AGREE WITH THE LA THOSE
SECOND AND THIRD RECOMMENDATION
FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH I.
I'M.
THESE ARE BIG NUMBERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT AREA. FOR THE ECONOMY
OF THE STATE SO.
THANKS THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
YES MA'AM.
I JUST LIKE TO COMMENT ON YOUR
YOUR.
COMMENT ABOUT THEM NOT FUNDING
THE ADDITIONAL RSI HOURS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THE
ESTIMATES THAT WE GET IN.
EVEN IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ARE STILL ESTIMATES
THERE STILL PROJECTIONS AND
WE'VE JUST RECEIVED I GUESS
EVERY SPRING. THE.
BOTH K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SPONSORS SUBMIT REVISED
RSI HOURS THERE PROVIDING TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
AND THEN WE WILL ADJUST THEM SO
MAY REVISION WILL LIKELY ADJUST
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OR SI
HOURS.
SO WE THINK IT'S KIND OF
PREMATURE TO FIND PROJECTED
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN HOURS WHEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ISN'T EVEN
CERTIFIED YET. SO WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT NEXT YEAR WE WILL
PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO MEET THE PERSON.
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
PROJECTIONS WHEN THE DATA IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
SHARE YOUR OPINION THAT THE LA
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR.
ANTICIPATED OUR SIZES IS.
.
LITTLE TOO EARLY.
SO YOU'RE SAYING BASICALLY WE
THINK WE SHOULD WAIT ANOTHER
YEAR UNTIL WE HAVE MUCH BETTER.
PROJECTIONS THE DATA CERTIFIED
THAT THESE HOURS HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN PROVIDED MY ONLY CONCERN
WOULD BE IS THAT I THINK THIS IS
A GROWING AREA.
AND IF WE SHOULD S. SUBMIT.
BY DOING THIS ACTION IT WOULD BE
SENATOR MESSAGE THE COMMUNICABLE
EDGES.
AND THE.
.
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE DOING THE
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS THAT THIS
IS GONNA BE CONTINUE INVESTMENT
BY THE STATE IN THIS AREA. I
AGREE WITH YOU AS FAR AS THE
FUNDING ISSUE.
BUT I THINK WE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO. PUSH US AS AN
IMPORTANT AREA OF INVESTMENT IN
EDUCATION.
I THINK WE'RE ALSO HOPING THAT
ARE PROPOSAL TO ALLOW SOME
COURSES TO BE FUNDED TO
APPORTIONMENT WOULD FREE UP OUR
INSIDE OUT ON OUR SIDE AHLERS.
AND THOSE DOLLARS COULD ACTUALLY
BE USED TO FUND EXPANSIONS IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THIS POINT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HASN'T PAPER TO GIVE US
YOU KNOW AN IDEA ABOUT HOW MANY
COURSES MIGHT SHIFT AT A PORTION
RIGHT NOW CHANCES GODDESS WHO
WORKED AT HOME. HERE THAT. WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO A LOT
OF AREAS.
THIS PROBABLY MY LAST HEARING ON
THIS AND I'M GOING TO BE LOOKING
IN THIS.
PLACE AT THE END OF THE YEAR
BUT.
JUST I'M VERY HAPPY HOW THIS IS
GONE OVER THE SIX YEARS NINE ONE
CONTINUE TO GO TO.
THAT'S WHY I'M WAYNE AND THOSE
POINT.
BUT I APPRECIATE.
YOU COMMENT I'D BE HERE NOW THAT
YOU HAVE PROBABLY TAKEN UP BUT
I'M NOT.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING ON ALL THESE
MISCELLANEOUS TOPICS.
THING NO MORE.
I QUESTIONS THAT WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO CERTIFIED
NURSES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MOLLY
COSWORTH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AS PART OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT S. B.
NINETY SEVEN REQUIRED THAT
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS WERE
CMA'S. WHO WORK AT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES HAVE TO
PROVIDE AT LEAST TWO POINT FOUR
HOURS OF DIRECT CARE SERVICES?
PER DAY FOR EACH PATIENT.
THIS NEW STEPPING REQUIREMENT
WILL GO INTO EFFECT ON JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE NURSING
CARE FOR CHRONICALLY ILL OR
SHORT TIME SHORT TERM RESIDENTS.
ALONG WITH REHAB AND SPECIALIZED
MEDICAL PROGRAMS.
C. N. A.'S PROVIDE BASIC NURSING
ASSISTANCE AND HELP RESIDENTS
WITH ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING.
AND PLAY A KEY ROLE IN RESIDENT
CARE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
ESTIMATES THAT OVER FORTY
PERCENT OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WILL HAVE TO INCREASE
THEIR C. N. A STEPPING LEVELS TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE
NEW MINIMUM STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL CSA'S WILL BE
NEEDED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
TO HELP ADDRESS THIS ANTICIPATED
SHORTAGE THE GOVERNORS BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO MILLION AND ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. ADMINISTERED
BY THE COMMUNICABLE EDGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS TO STRONG
WORKFORCE REGIONAL CONSORTIA TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CDNAS
BEING TRAINED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
CURRENTLY ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
COLLEGES OFFER THE CERTIFICATE
PROGRAM WHICH TYPICALLY CAN BE
COMPLETED IN ONE SEMESTER. AND
REQUIRES ONE HUNDRED HOURS OF
SUPERVISED TRAINING THAT USUALLY
OCCURS AT THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY.
I WILL BE SPEAKING ON THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM IN A LATER
LATER AGENDA ITEM THIS MORNING.
BUT AT A HIGH LEVEL THE PROGRAM
WAS CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. TO DEVELOP JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND EIGHT GEOGRAPHICAL
REGIONS ACROSS THE STREET.
WHICH ARE LINED WITH THE
REGION'S LOCAL LABEL MYRRH LABOR
MARKET DEMAND.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ABOUT FORTY SIX
MILLION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION PROVIDED FOR THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. WAS SPENT ON
PROGRAMS TO TRAIN STUDENTS IN A
VARIETY OF HEALTH CARE FIELDS
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE CNA NURSING
TRAINING PERCY ANY TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING FUND WHICH IS FUNDED BY
A TAX ON CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS.
TO PROVIDE TRAINING FUNDS FOR
EMPLOYERS TO IMPROVE THE SKILLS
OF THEIR WORKERS.
IT IS ANTICIPATED THAT SOME OF
THIS ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION WILL
GO OUT THROUGH CONTRACTS WITH
SKILLED NERVE NURSING
FACILITIES.
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CDNAS
BEING TRAINED. THIS PART OF
FUNDING IS BEING CONSIDERED IN A
SEPARATE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
I'D BE HAPPY AT YOUR QUESTIONS.
ELIOT.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CONTAINS
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS RELATED TO
A CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
CNA STAFFING.
AND THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
THE.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ADDRESSES MEDI
CAL FUNDING FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
TO HELP THEM MEET THEIRHIGHER
STAFFING COSTS THAT WILL BE
EXPECTED IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
HAS A PROPOSAL HAS A PROPOSAL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF.
PUBLIC HEALTH'S BUDGET.
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL OF
FUNDING WHICH.
MISS BECAUSE OF I JUST
MENTIONED.
AND THEN YOU ALSO HAVE THIS
PROPOSAL FOR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SUPPORTED GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO OUR
OFFICES.
CLOSE TO RELEASING AN ANALYSIS
THAT COVERS ALL OF THESE ARE
PROPOSALS THIS PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS TODAY OF COURSE RISK
SUBCOMMITTEE IS FOCUSING JUST ON
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. PIECE OF
THAT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GRANTS
AND. YOUR COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES WILL COVER THOSE
OTHER ISSUES.
SO.
AS ARE MISSED BECAUSE OF OCT
MENTIONED THE NEW STATE LAW GOES
INTO EFFECT JULY FIRST AND IT'S
GOING TO RESULT IN HUNDREDS OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
NEEDING TO HIRE A TOTAL OF ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND ROUGHLY TWO
THOUSAND MORE CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANTS AND THE CNAC REALLY
PROVIDE. THE KIND OF THE
BACKBONE OF THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY IN TERMS OF THE TRACK
CARE THEY PROVIDE HELPING.
PATIENTS PRIMARILY OLDER ADULTS
WITH BATHING FEEDING THEM
DRESSING ON THE AND THOSE SORTS
OF TASKS.
TO THE EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO ASSIST SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES IN THE NEAR
TERM BY PROVIDE BY FUNDING MORE.
SLOTS MORE TRAINING SLOTS.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
MODIFY THE GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL
IN TWO WAYS NOT ALL GO OVER
THOSE TWO.
FIRST
THE GOVERNOR LIMITS IS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GRANT
PROPOSAL TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CNA TRAINING PROGRAMS
YET THE SCHOOL DISTRICT RUN
ADULT SCHOOLS OF WHICH ARE ALSO
FUNDED BY PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT.
I ACTUALLY.
OFFER EVEN MORE TRAINING
PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I INCLUDING ADULT SCHOOLS IN
THESE GRANTS WITH US BROADEN THE
REACH
OF THE FUNDING.
ALLOW. MORE REGIONS AND IN
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE A.
A PROGRAM HEREBY THAT THEY COULD
BE INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS IN AND. GENERATING MORE
TRAIN SEE AN ACE.
INCLUDING ADULTS SCHOOLS ALSO
WITH LEVERAGE THE STATE'S
RECENTLY CREATED ADULT ADD
CONSORTIUM PROGRAM WHICH IS
INTENDED TO FOSTER COLLABORATION
AND COMMUNICATION.
BETWEEN ADULTS SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN AND GIVEN
REGION'S AND YOU'LL YOU'LL TALK
ABOUT ADULT ADD IN THE NEXT
ITEM.
WITH US RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE MODIFY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING BY
INCLUDING ADULTS SCHOOLS IN THE
GRANTS RATHER THAN APPROPRIATING
FUNDS THROUGH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM
THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE THE THREAT
FUNDS THROUGH THE ADULT.
EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT.
UNDER THIS APPROACH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WOULD BE CHARGED
WITH JOINTLY AWARDING
DISTRIBUTING AND OVERSEEN GRANT
FUNDS TO ADULT SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN EACH
CONSORTIUM.
TO PROMOTE REGIONAL COORDINATION
COMMUNICATION WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED TO
BUILD SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO NOTIFY EACH OTHER
THAT THEY'RE APPLYING FOR THESE
FUNDS SO THEY CAN THEY CAN.
TALK MORE IN AND PLAN WHERE YOU
PLAN BETTER.
SO I SAID EARLIER THERE WERE WE
HAD TO.
RECOMMENDED MODIFICATIONS THE
FIRST DESIGN INCLUDING ADULT
SCHOOLS AND THE.
IN THE GRANT PROPOSAL THIS
SECONDS ARE THE SECOND PROPOSAL
CONCERNS CHANGING MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS FOR C. N. A
INSTRUCTORS THAT THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE NEEDED TO.
TEACH A LARGER AND MORE COHORTS
OF OF CNA STUDENTS.
SO IN THE COURSE OF RESEARCHING
AND ANALYZING THE GOVERNOR'S CNA
PROPOSAL WE SPOKE WITH A NUMBER
OF CNA PROGRAM DIRECTORS BOTH
THAT COMMUNICABLE EDGES AN ADULT
SCHOOLS.
IN GENERALLY THAT DIRECTORS
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE WAIT
LISTS
OF STEEL OF ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
TRYING TO GET INTO A PROGRAM SO.
SO IT'S NOT AN ISSUE OF.
.
SO YOU REALLY HAVE A POTENTIAL
WORKFORCE SUPPLY YOU HAVE THAT
THE SUPPLY AT THE READY. TO TO
GET INTO THE SLOTS
BUT WHAT WE HEARD AGAIN AND
AGAIN FROM TALKING WITH THESE
PROGRAMS IS THAT THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
EXPAND ENROLLMENTS THEY WILL NOT
BE ABLE FOR THE MOST PART TO USE
THESE. GRANT MONIES ARE THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO HER
PROVIDE WITHOUT A CHANGE IN THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS FOR
INSTRUCTORS WHAT THEY TOLD US AS
THE THE THEN THE ANSWER. THEIR
QUALIFICATIONS TO BECOME A CNA
INSTRUCTOR ARE SO GREAT THAT
THEY JUST CAN'T FIND.
YEAH INSTRUCTORS TO TEACH THE
CLASS EVEN IF THEY'RE THE BAY
HAD LOTS OF EXPERIENCE ARE IN
THE FIELD.
AND THE REASON FOR THIS
DISQUALIFICATION ISSUE IS STATE
REGULATIONS CURRENT STATE
REGULATIONS REQUIRE SEE AN
INSTRUCTOR BE A LICENSED NURSE
WITH AT LEAST ONE YEAR OF DIRECT
CARE EXPERIENCE IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY.
AND SO THAT'S PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE.
YOU HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF OUR
ENDS FOR EXAMPLE WHO HAVE
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE PROVIDING
DIRECT CARE BUT THE DIRECT CARE
IS PROVIDED AN ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL NOT IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AS A RESULT.
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE EVEN
APPLIED TO BE AN INSTRUCTOR IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
UNLIKE WHAT OTHER STATES DO.
ARE YOU SIMILARLY YOU HAVE
NURSES WHO WORK IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY.
THEY OVERSEE THE C. N. AIDS FOR
EXAMPLE.
WE'LL THEY WOULDN'T THEY
WOULDN'T GET TO BE ELIGIBLE
COULD BE CONSIDERED ELIGIBLE TO
BE AN INSTRUCTOR EITHER BECAUSE
THEY DON'T PROVIDE DIRECT CARE.
THE PATIENT
IN THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
SO AND WE LOOKED AT THE. THERE
ARE ACTUALLY ARE SOME FEDERAL
REGULATIONS ON MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS AND CALIFORNIA'S.
SEED THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS OF
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS JUST TALK
ABOUT A NURSES NEED TO HAVE A
YEAR OF NURSING OF OF EXPERIENCE
IN THE PROVISION OF. OUR LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY SERVICES
THERE'S NOTHING THERE ABOUT
DIRECT CARE.
IN THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
SO.
WE TALKED TO.
ADULT SCHOOLS AS I MENTIONED
AND THEY SAID.
WELL IN ADDITION TO THE PROBLEM
OF FINDING.
SEE AN ACE THAT HAVE THAT CNA
INSTRUCTORS RATHER THAT HAVE
THAT DIRECT CARE EXPERIENCE IN A
SNAP. NEW SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY THEY HAVE ANOTHER.
HURDLE THEY NEED TO FIND AN
INSTRUCTOR THAT HAS A. TEACHING
CREDENTIAL
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
REQUIRED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THESE
INSTRUCTORS HAVE TO HAVE A
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
TEACHING CREDENTIAL. SO WHAT%
THESE ARE ADULT EDUCATION ADULT
SCHOOL PROGRAM DIRECTOR SAID IS
THAT IT'S IT'S HARD TO FIND A IS
SUCH INDIVIDUALS.
AND DIE AS A RESULT THEY FEEL
THAT THEY WOULD BE HARD PRESSED.
THE CITADEL'S SCHOOLS AS WELL AS
A COMMUNICATIVE TO EXPAND
ENROLLMENTS.
SO A.
IN TANDEM WITH PROVIDING GRANTS
TO ADULT SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THROUGH WOULD BE A BILL
THAT CONSORTIUM WHICH IS OUR
FIRST RECOMMENDATION. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE CHANGE
STATUTE TO ALLOW MORE TYPES
OF NURSES TO QUALIFY AS SEEN A
INSTRUCTORS.
SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMEND THE
NEW POLICY ALLOW NURSES TO
SERVICE INSTRUCTORS IF THEY'VE
HAD EXPERIENCE PROVIDING CARE IN
AN ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL OR OTHER
FACILITY. THAT PROVIDES A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF CARE FOR
OLDER ADULTS OR THE CHRONICALLY
ILL. AND WE ALSO RECOMMEND
PERMITTING AS INSTRUCTORS NURSES
WHO DON'T PROVIDE DIRECT CARE
AND A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
BUT SUPERVISE SEE AN ACE IN MAY
OF IN THE PAST HAD DIRECT CARE
EXPERIENCE. IN A ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL OR ELSEWHERE.
SO THESE CHANGES WOULD MAKE
RECRUITING AND HIRING
INSTRUCTORS LAST DIFFICULT FOR
PROVIDERS WELL CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT INSTRUCTORS MEET
FEDERER FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
SO TO HELP ADULTS SCHOOLS IN
HIRING INSTRUCTORS AND ALIGN THE
REQUIREMENTS WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE AMEND STATUTES. ARE
SO THAT INDIVIDUALS NO LONGER
NEED A TEACHING CREDENTIAL TO
SERVE AS A. CNA INSTRUCTOR IN
THE ADULT SCHOOLS.
AND WITHOUT SUCH CHANGES TO
MINIMUM INSTRUCTOR
QUALIFICATIONS
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT AUGMENTING
FUNDING FOR MORE TRAIN SLOTS
LIKELY WOULD HAVE LITTLE EFFECT
AND MUCH OF THE GRANT FUNDING
WOULD GO UNUSED.
THANK YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CHRIS US WONDER THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AGAIN WE THINK THIS IS A
REASONABLE PROPOSAL TO USE ONE
TIME RESOURCES.
TO ADDRESS IDENTIFIED NEED.
TO THE TWO ISSUES THAT THE THAT
THE ANALYST.
RAISED UP YOU KNOW I THINK ON
THE GRANT PROGRAM OF THAT WITH
THE FUNDING WE THINK MAKES SENSE
WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE COLLEGES
CURRENTLY OFFERING OF THESE
PROGRAMS. WE DO THINK THAT IT
MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO USE A
DIFFERENT.
WAY OF DISTRIBUTING THE FUNDING
TO OUR COLLEGES THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. BUT YOU KNOW
PART OF THE RATIONALE OF THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAMS THAT
REGION'S ARE DECIDING UPON NEEDS
AND ALLOCATING.
STRONG WORKFORCE DOLLARS TO
HIGHEST PRIORITIES IF THIS IS A
CASE WHERE WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE
TYPE OF PROGRAM WE'RE TRYING TO
SEEK HIM WERE PROVIDING ONCE HAD
RESOURCES. IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE
YOU KNOW WE THINK TO TO ALLOCATE
THESE DOLLARS TO COLLEGES AND I
SPENT A MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD
WAY.
ON THE.
ISSUE OF MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS.
.
WE YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
A BROADER SENSE ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STRONG
WORKFORCE TASK FORCE TWO YEARS
AGO. WAS THAT WE CONSIDER
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS FOR CT
INSTRUCTOR SO I THINK WE.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK BE THE
PANELISTS POINT MAKES SENSE AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE HAPPY
TO LOOK FOR A LOOK AT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SOMETHING THAT. WE HAVE
BEEN DOING WORK INTERNALLY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE THINK ABOUT
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS WE'VE.
MOVE FORWARD WITH SOME CHANGES
TO MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS FOR
APPRENTICESHIP INSTRUCTORS AND I
SO I THINK THIS IS HOW. THE
CONVERSATION THAT WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH WHERE ARE
SYSTEMS BEEN LIVING.
THE ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS.
THING THAT I KNOW WILL HAVE SOME
DISCUSSION. IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
P. SO WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
AS WELL.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ADULT
EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN CARE MCCARTY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MOLLY COSWORTH
WITH FINANCE.
BOSTON HOUSE AND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE BE
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW ON THE DOT
EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM OR
A E. BEACHY WHEN HE PRESENTS LA
OWES RECOMMENDATIONS. SO I WON'T
GO INTO A LOT OF PROGRAM DETAIL
NOW.
THE EIGHTY BG PROGRAM WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN TWO THOUSAND%
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WITH DEDICATED
ON GOING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION IN
WHICH A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ENTITIES IN THE SAME REGION
WHILE PROVIDING ALL ADULT
EDUCATION. WITH LITTLE OR NO
COORDINATED PLANNING AS TO WHAT
KIND OF SERVICES THEY WERE
PROVIDING. AND THE KINDS OF
POPULATIONS THEY WERE SERVING.
THE AGB PROGRAM WAS DEVELOPED
WITH A GREAT DEAL OF INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND REQUIRED ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDERS AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AN ADULT SCHOOLS.
OPERATING IN CAPE WHO TWELVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN CONCERT WITH OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
LIBRARIES.
TO COME TOGETHER TO FORM
REGIONAL CONSORTIA AND JOINTLY
DEVELOP THREE YEAR REGIONAL
PLANS AS TO HOW BEST TO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THEIR ADULT
LEARNERS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
FOR CHANGES TO THE A. B. G.
PROGRAM.
FIRST A E. BG CONSORTIA WILL
RECEIVE UP FOUR POINT ONE
PERCENT COST OF LIVING INCREASE.
EQUAL TO TWENTY POINT SIX
MILLION ADDED TO THE ON GOING
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION.
THE PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN. AND THIS
INCREASE WOULD PROVIDE A ONE
POINT FIFTY SIX COLA FOR TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND
A TWO POINT FIVE ONE PERCENT
COLA IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. WHICH
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE COLORS
PROVIDED FOR OTHER K. TWELVE
INCOMMUNICADO JUST PROGRAMS FOR
THESE TWO YEARS.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FUNDING
RECOGNIZES THE K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
HAVE FACED HIGHER COSTS TO
OPERATE THEIR PROGRAMS INCLUDING
HIGHER STEPPING COSTS FOR
SALARIES BENEFITS AND EMPLOYERS
CONTRA RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM A EACH BG
PROVIDERS THAT SOME PROGRAMS MAY
BE FORCED TO LAY OFF INSTRUCTORS
AND OFFER FEWER CLASSES TO ADULT
LEARNERS. DUE TO THESE RISING
COSTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN ON GOING INCREASE OF
FIVE MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR TING
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS. IN THE
EIGHTY BG DATA AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. TO ENSURE
THAT THE DATA BEING INPUT BY K.
THROUGH TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS. ARE
ACCURATE COMPREHENSIVE AND
CONSISTENT.
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE USED TO
CONTINUE EFFORTS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THE A BT DATA SHARING
PLATFORM. TO CREATE A UNIFIED
DATA SET THAT WILL CONTAIN
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ON THE
NUMBER OF ADULT LEARNERS THINGS
ARE BEING SERVED THE EXITS.
THE SUCCESS OF THE STUDENTS AS
THEY PROGRESS THROUGH THEIR
CLASSES AN OUTCOME DATA FOR THE
STUDENTS INCLUDING TRANSITION TO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
EMPLOYMENT AND WAGE DATA THAT
WILL BE PROVIDED THROUGH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
THE COTS THE COMPREHENSIVE
STUDENT DATA SET WILL BE
PROVIDED WILL BE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
LAUNCH BOARD DATA SHARING
PLATFORM.
THE FUNDING WE HOPE WILL ALSO BE
USED TO PROVIDE ONGOING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDERS TO INPUT
THEIR DATA CORRECTLY TO ENSURE
THAT HIGH QUALITY AND CONSISTENT
DATA. IS BEING COLLECTED FROM
THE VARIOUS PROVIDERS.
SAID THAT THIS DATA CAN BE USED
TO INFORM DECISIONS ABOUT
PROGRAM EXPANSIONS AND
IMPROVEMENTS AND TO CREATE NEW
PROGRAM COURSEWORK.
SOME OF THE FIVE MILLION WOULD
ALSO BE USED TO SURVEY STUDENTS
WHO DO NOT PROVIDE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS.
TO ASK ABOUT THEIR JOB IN PLACE
THEIR JOB PLACEMENT AND WAGES.
MANY ADULT EDUCATION STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN A REGION COURSES DO
NOT HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
SO THEY'RE NOT CAPTURED IN DDT'S
EMPLOYMENT AND WAGE DATA.
THIRDLY.
EACH OF THE SEVENTY ONE REGIONAL
CONSORTIA ARE REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT DEFINES
THE ADULT LEARNER POPULATIONS IN
THEIR REGION THE KINDS OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. THEY NEED
AND HOW EACH OF THE CONSORTIUM
MEMBERS WILL PROVIDE THE
SERVICES.
UNDER CURRENT STATUTE THE
INITIAL PLANNING CYCLE RUNS FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. AND COULDN'T SOURCE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING NOW
ON DEVELOPING THEIR NEXT PLAN
THAT WOULD GO INTO EFFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE AB BG OFFICE HAS REQUESTED
THAT THE CURRENT THREE YEAR
PLANNING CYCLE BE EXTENDED FOR
ONE ADDITIONAL YEAR THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. TO
GIVE CONSORTIUM PARTNERS AN
EXTRA YEAR TO DEVELOP THEIR PLAN
AS THEY MOVE FORWARD BEGINNING
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY.
WE AGREE THE EXTRA PLANNING
YEAR%
IS NEEDED SO THE CONSORTIA HAVE
ADEQUATE TIME.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE DATA
SHARING.
ACTIVITIES THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
FOR THAT THAT THE FIVE MILLION
WOULD PROVIDE. AND IT WOULDN'T
THEY WOULD HAVE BETTER DATA TO
ALIGN THEIR PROGRAMS TO WE JUST
THINK THERE ARE THERE PLANS
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WOULD BE BASED ON MUCH
BETTER DATA SO WE AGREE THAT.
THEY'D.
IT WOULD BE BETTER WITH ANOTHER
GEAR.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD REVISE THE EXISTING
AND TIMELINES.
AND FOURTH THEM WE'RE PROPOSING
TO CHANGE THE EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL FOR THAT TRAILER BILL FOR
EDUCATION.
TO CAP THE INDIRECT COST RATE
THAT HOME.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE CHARGE THEIR
ADULT EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
WE WOULD CAP THIS AT NO MORE
THAN THE INDIRECT COST RATE THAT
WAS CHARGED IN THE PRIOR YEAR.
OR AT NO MORE THAN FIVE PERCENT
OF THE I. EACH CONSORTIUMS THEM
TOTAL THE EPG ALLOCATION. AND
WE'VE HEARD THAT SOME ADULTS
SCHOOLS ARE BEING CHARGED TEN
PERCENT OR GREATER IN THEIR
INTEREST COST RATE.
SO THAT ENHANCE MY COMMENTS ON
THIS PROGRAM AND I'M. HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
OUR OFFICE WAS CHARGED WITH.
IDENTIFYING UNRESOLVED ALIGNMENT
IN COORDINATION ISSUES.
THAT.
.
THEY CONTINUE TO IMPEDE THE
ABILITY OF ADULT SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO WORK
TOGETHER IN A COORDINATED WAY
AND TO SERVE STUDENTS IN A WAY.
THAT PROVIDES
RELATIVELY EQUAL ACCESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ADULT
LEARNERS AND ACCESS TO QUALITY
SERVICES SO SOMETHING. WE DID IN
YOUR.
.
YOUR AGENDA INCLUDES A SUMMARY
TABLE.
ON PAGE TEN.
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT WE
IDENTIFIED.
THIS SERGEANT ACTUALLY USED THIS
IS WELL AS THIS DISTRIBUTED A.
THAT TABLE.
WHICH MIGHT BE EASIER FOR YOU
TO READ.
AND SO. ALL GO THROUGH A KIND OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF OF THAT.
TABLE OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
AND THEN BASED ON.
WHAT WE WHAT WE OUTLINED HERE
THINK IT'LL HELP?
BETTER HELP YOU.
A BETTER UNDERSTAND.
AND BE BETTER INFORMED ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ON THE
AUGMENTATION.
AND THAT FOUR POINT ONE PERCENT
AUGMENTATION AND THEN THE DATA.
ISSUES.
SO JUST TO START.
ON THE TOP ROW OF THAT TABLE.
I NOTES THAT STUDENT IDENTIFIERS
REMAIN AN UNRESOLVED ISSUE.
CURRENTLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
USE.
STUDENTS SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
OR A UNIQUE IDENTIFIER.
STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER AND THEY USE
THAT FOR TO PUT IT INTO THEIR
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM.
AND TO FOLLOW STUDENTS AND SEE
HOW THEY'RE DOING LOOK AT
OUTCOMES.
K. TWELVE THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
HAS A STATEWIDE STUDENT
IDENTIFIER UNIQUE IDENTIFIER FOR
EACH STUDENT THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL.
BUT THEN WHAT'S THAT STUDENT THE
STUDENT WERE TO LEAVE OR LET'S
SAY DROP OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
RETURN AS ADULT STUDENTS.
GENERALLY ADULT SCHOOLS WOULD
GIVE THAT STUDENT A LOCAL
IDENTIFIER NOT THAT OLD
STATEWIDE STUDENT IDENTIFIER
GENERALLY ALSO. IF YOU HAVE A
STUDENT IT'S NOT FROM THAT
DIDN'T GO TO K. TWELVE CASE GO
THROUGH K. TWELVE IN CALIFORNIA
THEY'LL GET. A LOCAL IDENTIFIER
AS WELL.
AND AGAIN THESE IDENTIFIERS ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THE WHAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE SO YOU
HAVE IS A SYSTEM.
THAT.
.
DOES NOT MAKE IT VERY EASY FOR
THE PROVIDERS.
AND FOR CHANCES OFFICE AND
CALIFORNIA PART OF EDUCATION NO
LEGISLATURE FOR THAT MATTER. TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE STUDENTS ARE
DOING TO FOLLOW THEM FROM THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM.
TWO ADULT EDUCATION.
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES MAYBE
TO UNIVERSITY OF WORKFORCE AND
SO THAT THAT'S OF A BIG ISSUE
AND WE RECOMMEND THAT ADULT
SCHOOL START USING STATEWIDE
STUDENT IDENTIFIERS.
AND IF THE IT THAT THAT A BILL
THAT STUDENT WAS ONCE IN THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM TO GET THAT THAT
NUMBER BACK NUMBER THEN WE
REQUIRE THAT. WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE ADULT SCHOOLS SHARE THOSE
STATEWIDE IDENTIFIERS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND PRETTY
MANY COLLEGES.
TO.
INCORPORATE IDENTIFIERS IN
THEIR DATA SYSTEM
SEC THAT'S ONE ISSUE IN IN THE
SO COME BACK YOU WILL COME BACK
TO THAT WHEN WE GET TO THE
GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSALS ON DATA.
I WILL NOT GO THROUGH EACH ONE
OF THESE BUT THE HIGHLIGHT THE
MAJOR ONES AS FAR AS A LINEMAN
ISSUES A BIG ONE IS STATE
FUNDING. AND COURSE FEES
RIGHT NOW. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS VERY DIFFERENT
FUNDING POLICIES AND FEE
POLICIES
DEPENDING ON WHETHER IT'S. AN
ADULT SCHOOL OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RELY
PRIMARILY ON A PORTION MINUTES
FOR ADULT ADD.
INSTRUCTION.
WHICH THEY CALL NON CREDIT AND
THERE'S A SET
S. STATUTORILY STACKED SET. UP
PER STUDENT RATE.
NOW DOLE SCHOOLS GET THEIR
MONEY.
THROUGH IT ALL THAT BLOCK GRANTS
THAT'S THEIR STATE MONEY AND
THERE IS NO SET PER STUDENT
RATE.
I IT'S UP TO EACH INDIVIDUAL%
ADULT SCHOOL TO DECIDE WHAT.
WHAT THEY WANT TO FIND AND AND
HOW RICH LEAD TO FIND A
INSTRUCTION?
AND WE KNOW FROM SPEAKING WITH
ADULTS SCHOOLS THAT FUNDING PER
STUDENT VARIES QUITE A BIT FROM
AREA TO AREA FROM ADULT SCHOOL
THEY DON'T ADULT SCHOOL.
NOW FOR A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION CT COURSES MANY ADULT
SCHOOLS ARE FORCED TO SUPPLEMENT
STATE FINDING THAT BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING WITH FEES.
AND YOU SEE YOU GREAT VARIATION
AROUND THE STATE IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH ADULT LEARNERS ARE CHARGED
FOR COMPARABLE.
INSTRUCTION FOR COMPARABLE
PROGRAMS
WE JUST HAD THE ISSUE ON
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS.
IF YOU GO TO A Q. IF IF AN ADULT
LEARNER WHERE TO GO TO AN ADULT
TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THEY WOULD NOT BE CHARGED.
A FEE.
TO GO TO THAT SEE IN A TRAINING
PROGRAM.
OR IF THERE WAS SOME SORT OF FEE
THAT STUDENT ALMOST ALWAYS WHICH
WOULD GET A STATE.
FUNDED
FEE WAIVER THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO
PAY.
IT'S NOT THE CASE WITH ADULTS
SCHOOLS WE LOOK AT ADULTS
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SOME CHARGE UP TO ONE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR A
SEMESTER LIKE PROGRAM NOT
BECAUSE THEY. LIKE TO NOT SO
THEY WANT TO DO IT'S BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE FUNDING FOR THE
BLOCK GRANT THAT WOULD SUPPORT
THAT INSTRUCTION THEY IN ORDER
TO OFFER THAT. THAT COURSE THAT
PROGRAM THEY CHARGE FEES SO JUST
DEPENDING ON WHERE AN ADULT
LEARNER.
LIVES THEY'RE GOING TO
EXPERIENCE QUITE A BIT OF
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE FEES
THEY PAY.
SO.
THESE ARE THESE ARE SOME BIG
ISSUES YOU KNOW FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. TO TO TACKLE
AND.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT MIGHT
TAKE A FEW MORE YEARS.
TO TO REALLY IMPLEMENT YOU
DECIDE AND AND TO IMPLEMENT
CHANGES HOW HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
CREATE A BETTER ACCESS AND A
MORE COMPARABLE. A.
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS
AROUND THE STATE. LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO START WITH SOME MORE
MODEST.
A UNRESOLVED ISSUES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED FOR EXAMPLE IN THE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE TABLE YOU SEE
OF THE ISSUE OF COORDINATION
WITH OTHER ADULT EDUCATION.
FUNDS CURRENTLY YOU HAVE A STATE
A OF LIBRARIES AND OTHER.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT RECEIVE
STATE FUNDING FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR ADULT EDUCATION.
BUT CURRENTLY THEY'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
LOCAL CONSORTIA
NOT AT THE TABLE NOT PROVIDING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING NOT COORDINATING NOT
CREATING. LADDERS FOR FOR
STUDENTS AND PATHWAYS FOR
STUDENTS.
TO TO ADVANCE.
IN THEIR LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
A RELATIVELY SIMPLE
RECOMMENDATION OF OURS IS TO
REQUIRE ALL OF THESE ADULT AT
PROVIDERS TO BE PART OF THEIR
REGIONAL CONSORTIA. AND FOR THE
REGIONAL CONSORTIA INTERN TO.
TO WELCOME THEM YOU KNOW AT THE
TABLE AND INCLUDE ARE ALL OF
THESE PROVIDERS IN THE PLANS OF
WHATTHEY'RE FINDING AND AND HOW
THEY'RE CREATING BETTER
PROGRAMS.
FOR STUDENTS.
ANOTHER ISSUE SECOND FROM BOTTOM
OF BOTTOM ROW IS MINIMUM
INSTRUCTOR QUALIFICATIONS THIS
IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I I
MENTIONED IN THE. EARLIER ITEM
ON CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS.
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE.
ADULT SCHOOLS AND COMMITTEE
COLLEGES TEACHING THE SAME OR
SIMILAR CONTENT YET STATE HAS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS FOR WHAT.
IT'S TEACHER NEEDS TO HAVE IN
ORDER TO TEACH IN THOSE
PROGRAMS.
AND IF THE IF THE INSTRUCTORS
TEACHING AN ADULT SCHOOL THEY
NEED TO HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL WHEREAS IF THEY'RE
TEACHING THAT COMMITTEE COLLEGES
THEY DO NOT NEED TO DO TEACHING
CREDENTIAL. SIZE RESULT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS.
WITHOUT A TEACHING CREDENTIAL
SO WE RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE
DROP THAT A CREDENTIALING
REQUIREMENT FOR ADULTS EDUCATIVO
INSTRUCTORS. ARE NOT JUST FOR C.
N. A.'S BUT BUT FOR OTHER.
INSTRUCTIONAL AREAS AS WELL.
SO WE GET TO THE GOVERNOR
SPECIFIC FUNDING PROPOSALS.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TWENTY
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THE BLOCK
GRANT.
GIVEN WHAT I JUST MENTIONED IT'S
HARD TO KNOW IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OR NOT.
A ENROLLMENT YOU WITH WITH K.
TWELVE IT'S MEASURED IN TERMS OF
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE EIGHTY
A. AND YOU KNOW.
FROM FOR COMMUNICABLE EDGES AND
UNIVERSITIES YET FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS F. T. E. S.
WHICH IS A MEASURE OF. OF
ENROLLMENT OF OF WORKLOAD.
WE DON'T KNOW CURRENTLY HOW
MANY FTA EASE ARE BEING SERVED.
BY THESE CONSORTIA IN THE STATE
WE WE HAVE HEAD COUNT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE.
WE DON'T HAVE EIGHTY A RAFTER E.
OR SOMETHING EQUIVALENT.
AND SO WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
WHETHER FD * GROWING NO
WORDS IT FLAT OR IS IT IS IT
GOING DOWN WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
WE LACK OTHER IMPORTANT INFO I
DATA THAT LEGISLATURE DOES TO
HELP SET OVERALL THE OVERALL
BLOCK GRANT FUNDING LEVEL WE
DON'T KNOW THE EXTENT OF UNMET
NEED IN THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE
OR.
HOW MUCH PROVIDERS ARE SPENDING
PER STUDENT?
US SO.
THESE ARE SOME CONSIDERATION THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW WHAT IS
GIVEN A LACK OF DATA WHAT IS THE
RIGHT LEVEL TO SET.
THAT'S SAID PROVIDING
AUGMENTATION ALONG THE LINES OF
THE FOUR POINT ONE PERCENT AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IT WOULD TREAT THE DAHLE
THAT BLOCK AROUND. BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM SIMILAR TO A LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE APPORTIONMENT
SIN AND SOME OTHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
AND IN THOSE CASES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED
AUGMENTATION A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS.
WITH REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE AYE DATA THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR DATA
RELATED OF PROJECTS WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THAT
FUNDING. PROPOSAL ARE IT WOULD
REALLY HELP THE LEGISLATURE GET
MORE ACCURATE AND MORE ACCURATE
PICTURE OF PROGRAM OUTCOMES AND
IN BETTER MONITOR.
HOW THE AT ALL THAT BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM IS PROGRESSING?
WE DO RECOMMEND IT ALONG WITH
THAT PROPOSAL HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO USE A PORTION OF
THOSE FINES TO ASSIGN US
STATEWIDE STUDENT IDENTIFIER. TO
ADULT STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE
THAT SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND
THEN FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO.
YOU COLLECTED MAINTAIN THOSE
IDENTIFIERS IN THE DATA SYSTEM
THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY BUILDING.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT. KIND OF
APPROACH WOULD ALLOW THE STATE
AND PROVIDERS TO BETTER ASSESS
HOW STUDENTS ARE MOVING FROM K.
TWELVE. TO ADULT SCHOOLS TO
COMMUNICATIVE ISN'T AND INTO THE
WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH VENABLE
HAVE A STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM PARKS
AND.
I JUST KNOW TO COUPLE THINGS ONE
IS THAT THAT THE SUPERINTENDENT
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THAT SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE AT
A COST OF LIVING INCREASE FOR
I'M. FEDERAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
FOR THE REASONS MATH QUIZ BY TH
NOTED WHICH IS THAT THEY'VE SEEN
RISING COSTS BUT.
UP FLAT FUNDING I'M ADDITIONAL
I'M ALSO GOING TO PROVIDE SOME
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE END
OF YOUR REPORT ON IMPLEMENTATION
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF THE ADULT
ED. EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT REPORT
FOR SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN I I WILL
NOTE THAT THAT THE. REPORT IS
BEING FINALIZED NOW ACT OF FIGHT
NEAR FINAL DRAFT WAS PROVIDED TO
THE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT
THE DEPARTMENT DID HAVE THAT THE
DRAFT FOR AWHILE WHEN WE
REVIEWED IT. FIRST WE HAD SOME.
DATA ISSUES I NEED TO DO SOME
BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
CONTRACTOR AND THAT TOOK LONGER
THAN ANTICIPATED AND JUST JUST
TO SAY. THAT WE HAD INTENDED TO
BE THAT LONG WE ARE LOOKING AT
WAYS THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAINST THAT
WE DO MEET THAT. THE TIMELINE ON
THE REPORT BUT THAT SHOULD BE
FINALIZED VERY SOON.
AND SO IN THAT REPORT THOUGH
THERE COUPLE OF THINGS THAT ARE
JUST.
HIGHLIGHT ON NOT SO THE REPORT
ADDRESSES THE KEY REQUIREMENTS
OF THE LEGISLATION AND PROVIDE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS IT INCLUDES
COMPREHENSIVE STATE LEVEL DATA.
ON STUDENT ENROLLMENT OUTCOME
SKILLS GAINED STUDENTS THAT
STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS AND OTHER
DATA USING THE AT NEW ADULT
EDUCATION DATA AND
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS THAT WE
SEE THE CONSORTIA HAS SERVED.
JUST OVER SIX HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND I'M. AS ADULTS IN
THE PROGRAM'S ABOUT SIXTY SIX
PERCENT OF THOSE WERE IN K.
TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS. I'M OF
THOSE SHOULD JUST SHY OF SIX
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND MORE
WERE ENROLLED IN ONE OF THE
SEVEN EBT PROGRAM AREAS. AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND OF THEM
RECEIVE SERVICES INSTEAD
INCLUDING PARTICIPATING IN
WORKSHOPS. EDUCATIONAL CAREER
PLANNING ASSESSMENT BUT DIDN'T
ACTUALLY ENROLL IN A PROGRAM
IT'S AS WE LOOK AT THOSE THE
SEVEN PROGRAMS THE REPORT
OUTLINES THAT THE INVOLVEMENT
FOR THOSE. I AM ON THE DATA WE
DO IF WE LOOK BACK AT SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND OF THE
ADULTS PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM'S COMPLETED A MEASURABLE
SKILL GAIN. WHEN EDUCATION
MILESTONES WE SAW SIXTEEN
THOUSAND AND ADULT COMPLETING A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
EQUIVALENT AND NOT JUST SHY OF
ELEVEN THOUSAND RECEIVINGPOST
SECONDARY CERTIFICATES OR
DEGREES AND TRAININGS. AND THEN
AT I'D JUST ABOUT THIRTEEN
THOUSAND TRANSITIONING TO POST
SECONDARY WILL ALSO THE REPORT
ALSO OUTLET SOME SOME WAGE DATA
SO I AM. ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ADULTS AND ENTERED THE
EMPLOYMENT AND ABOUT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND TO INCREASE WAGES AND
TO THE REPORT PROVIDES MORE
DETAIL. ON THAT.
AS FAR AS RECOMMENDATIONS GO SO
THAT I IN THAT WE RECOMMEND THAT
THEY CREATE THAT AND THE
LEGISLATURE CREATE A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR PERFORMANCE BASED
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR ADULT
EDUCATION CONSORTIA. AND THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE RECOMMENDS THAT THAT AND
THAT BE ALLOCATED.
TO ADMINISTER AND AN INCENTIVE
FUND WILL ALSO RECOMMEND
ALLOCATING ANNUAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT DATE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEMS FOR ADULT EDUCATION.
CREATING A DEDICATED ANNUAL
ALLOCATION FOR STATEWIDE SYSTEMS
OF OPERATION FOR ADULT EDUCATION
AND ALIGN THE FEDERAL AND STATE
REPORTING CYCLES AND WITHOUT
ALTERNATIVE AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE BUTJUST TO KNOW THAT I'M
AVAILABLE AND ALSO. DONNA WHITE
WHO IS OUR DIRECTOR OF THAT
CAREER IN COLLEGE TRANSITION
DIVISION ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU KRISHNASWAMY WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENTS.
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS WORK.
ON THE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL WE THINK THE FOUR
POINT ONE PERCENT INCREASE MAKES
SENSE WE ARE ESPECIALLY.
WITH.
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DATA WORK OF OUR
DATA MORE BROADLY THE ANALYST
SUSPENSION AND.
CHALLENGES WITH SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS I WILL JUST NOTE.
ONE BILL AB TWENTY SIXTY.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
SEEKS TO IMPROVE DATA LINKAGES
BETWEEN STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
THE DAM PM EDT TO IMPROVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF OUTCOMES FOR CT
PROGRAMS GENERALLY INCLUDING
ADULT EDUCATION.
ON THE FUNDING ISSUE I DO YOU
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT YOU KNOW
I THINK OF. YOU KNOW THE THE
ANALYSTS POINT IS THAT.
ACROSS THE STATE WE MIGHT SEE
DATA AND WE DO SEE DIFFERENT PER
STUDENT FUNDING RATES OF. ACROSS
THESE PROGRAMS BUT YOU KNOW I
THINK WE TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH I THINK YOU KNOW THE.
THE PHILOSOPHY OF THIS PROGRAM.
YEAH I THINK IT HAS THREE GOALS
ONE TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO.
ADULT ED PROGRAMS THE SECOND IS
PROBABLY TO IMPROVE QUALITY BY
LEAVING DECISIONS UP TO THE
LOCAL CONSORTIA TO FIGURE OUT
WHICH ARE THE. MOST APPROPRIATE
PROGRAMS TO.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING TWO AND THREE TO BUILD
YOU KNOW WHAT WE THINK OF IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS GUIDED
PATHWAYS THAT WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE TO. THROUGH THE CONSORTIA
YOU LIKELY HAVE IMPROVED
TRANSITIONS FROM AND ACROSS
ADULT SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND OTHER PROVIDERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. OF MUCH OF THE
INITIAL WORK ON WHETHER WE'RE
ACHIEVING THAT IS.
IS IN OUR DRAFT REPORT WHICH
THE.
YOUR AGENDA SUMMARIZES.
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR ABOUT HOW
WE GET MONEY FROM THE STATE TO
BE CONSORTIA THAT WE HAVE A
FORMULA IT'S NOT ENROLLMENT SURE
OF AND THAT WE HAVE A FORMULA
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE SIZE
OF THE ADULT POPULATION.
SCOTT MET MEASURES AROUND
LITERACY EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
IMMIGRANT AND IMMIGRATION. AND
THAT WE ALSO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
CONSORTIUM SIZING CAPACITY SO. I
DID IT I THINK WERE HAPPIER THAT
I KIND OF HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT THESE PER STUDENT
FUNDING RATES ARE AT THE
CONSORTIA SPENDING RATES. BUT I
DO THINK WE THINK IT.
.
A FORMULA FROM THE STATE LEVEL
OUGHT TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THINGS OTHER THAN.
ENROLLMENT AT THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT NEED I THINK YOU
CAN DO BOTH BUT WE SHOULD
PROBABLY HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW YOU DO THAT. ARMED
WITH REGARD AGAIN ON MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE
ACKNOWLEDGED AS PART OF OUR
SYSTEM. AND ARE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU.
TO THINK HOW WE DO THAT.
TAKE QUESTIONS.
YEAH BUT.
QUESTION AUTUMN BUT FIRST MR
CHAVIS.
WELL THIS REPORT REFLECTS.
PROBABLY THE GUIDANCE THAT WE
ESTABLISH BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
WHEN WE.
WELL THE PROPOSAL BY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WAS TO. DEFUND ADULT
EDUCATION AND.
AND EVERY WAS LIKE UP AT ARMS
BACK AT TWELVE THIRTEEN I
REMEMBER. IT WAS MY FIRST
SESSION BEING HERE SO.
WE WENT PUSH BACK ON THAT AND WE
ASK FOR HISTORICAL PRESENTATION
AND.
WAS INTERESTING ONE OF THE FIRST
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION WE HAD
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BAKKEN.
FORMATION OF THIS.
STATE NINETEEN SIXTY WAS ADULT
EDUCATION FOR LITERACY.
AND FOR CITIZENSHIP.
AND SO FOUND OUT IT HAD A WHOLE
HISTORY AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE STATE AND WHERE WE'RE GOING.
AND.
.
SO WE ASKED HIM TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT.
HOW WE COULD?
RECOGNIZE UNIQUENESS OF A RURAL
AREA IN AN URBAN AREA AND WHO IS
DOING THIS TO HIGH SCHOOLS. OR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT
WOULD BE THE BEST WAY TO
DETERMINE THAT BACK AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAD THIS DISCUSSION
TWELVE THIRTEEN. THERE WAS THE
INTRODUCTION THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING AND HAVING PEOPLE
LOCALLY BEST MAKE THE DECISIONS
IT WASN'T DECIDED AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
SO THIS KIND OF FOLLOWED IN WITH
THAT WHOLE DISCUSSION.
SO WE WE PUNTED DOWN TO LOCAL
PEOPLE YOU CONSORTIUM AND I TEND
A NUMBER OF MEETINGS IN MY OWN
DISTRICT. AND I CAN SAY IN WHAT
ONE PORTION MY DISTRICT IT WAS
RUN BY COMMUNITY COLLEGE YEARS
AND THE OTHER ONE IS RUN BY HIGH
SCHOOLS.
AND THAT WAS INTEREST IN SEEING
THE DISCUSSION COME OUT OTHERS
THE THINGS THAT THEY ARGUED
ABOUT BACK THEN AND I THINK THE
LA OKAY DRAWN AGAIN. WAS THE A
FUNDING MODEL.
YOU NO HOT. WHO'S GOING TO GET
THE MONEY WHO'S GONNA PAY FOR
IT.
THOUGH WHAT DEFINED IN
EXTRACTOR.
YOU KNOW.
WHERE THEY COME FROM WHAT WERE
THE QUALIFICATIONS?
AND ALSO THE DATA FAR HOW
REALLY DEFY THEM TO FIGURE OUT
THE GOING ONS OF. EVERYTHING THE
LA.
LAID OUT HERE WITH SOME OF THE
SAME DISCUSSIONS AT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE DOING ON THE SET
UP THE CONSORTIUM'S.
SO FAST FORWARD NOW A FEW YEARS
LATER. A.
COULD YOU QUICKLY MISS BROWN
BOTH USE THE SUCCESSES.
OF ADULT EDUCATION YOU HAD HOW
MANY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
INCREASE THEIR WAGES HOW MANY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. YOU KNOW
GOT CERTIFICATES YOU TO GIVE
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED
AGAIN GOING TO TAKE NOTES ON
THIS GOING TO USE IT LATER BY
AND I'M HAPPY TO TO PROVIDE WE
PROVIDED THE REPORT BUT I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU IN
AND THE NUMBERS BUT BUT WHAT I
AM. RECOUNTED IS IF WE LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF ADULTS BEING
SERVED BY THE PROGRAMS WE SEE.
AT ABOUT SIX HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND ADULTS BEING SERVED IN
THE PROGRAM AND WE DO HAVE A
BREAKDOWN WHICH AGAIN I CAN
PROVIDE FOR YOU. AROUND THE
AROUND THAT BY THE PROGRAM AREA
AT THAT FOR US THE SUCCESSES AS
WE LOOK AT IF WE SEE THE NUMBER
WHO HAVE. COMPLETED HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMAS THAT'S ABOUT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND. AND THE NUMBER WHO
HAVE A POST SECONDARY
CERTIFICATES DEGREES ARE
TRAINING IS AYE TEN THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THEN THAT THE
TRANSITION TO POST SECONDARY IS
TWELVE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED.
AND THEN IF WE SEE THE INCREASED
M. ARE AT HAVE ENTERED
EMPLOYMENT THAT IS SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND AND THEN INCREASE WAGES
THE SIXTEEN THOUSAND. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND I GET I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT TO YOU THOSE
SPECIFIC NUMBERS THAT'S GREAT SO
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND LIVES.
GREASE WAGES THAT'S FAMILIES
WERE TAKING CARE OF. IN A SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND AND EMPLOYMENT I
MEAN. THIS IS REALLY GOOD STUFF
FOR THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE
PUTTING IN HERE FOR THE STATE.
SO.
THE REQUEST I THINK WAS I HEARD
FROM THE FARM FINANCES BEEN
ANOTHER YEAR ON THE CONSORTIUM'S
ALLOWED TO GO FORWARD I GET THAT
RIGHT.
PROBABLY DANCE.
ANOTHER PLAN YOU'RE PROBABLY
ANSWER THE QUESTION THE LA O..
I WISH I'D BEEN HERE TO.
SHE IS COMING OUT NEXT YEAR BUT
I'M BE ROLE BUT THE.
I THINK THE.
SAME AS A PREVIOUS DISCUSSION
FOR THE NURSES AND THIS ONE
HERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD BILL IDEAS
IN.
ACTUALLY TO BRING FORWARD TO
CHANGE BECAUSE WE'RE POP WHERE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HERE WE'RE NOT
A POLICY.
WE HAVE ONE BIG BUILDING IN THE
AIR. BY A BILL YET BUT HAVE NOT
YET RATE PRIVATELY HELD IT ALL
UP IN THE ONE BILL YEAH YOU AND
I'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR A
COUPLE YEARS TOGETHER.
AS I THINK I WOULD FIND
INTERESTING THIS COMMITTEE.
GOES THROUGH UNANIMOUSLY BOTH
AND REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT OUT OF
ALL THE BUDGET COMMITTEES COULD
I THINK OF THE WORK WE DO. BUT
THE.
THIS IS GOOD STUFF
AND SO AYE WOOD DESK SUPPORTING
CREED INCREASING YEAR I THINK I
WOULD ALSO SAY THE LA L. HAS
MADE SOME REALLY GOOD ISSUES
THAT WE DISCUSSED SOME YEARS
AGO.
AND THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DISCUSSING LOCALLY IN THE
CONSORTIUM'S WHEN I GO ATTEND TO
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO.
.
I'LL BE SUPPORTED THESE CHANGES
FOR THE GOVERNOR. PUSH MY*
IS TO DO THIS. I THINK THIS IS
A.
A LOT OF SUCCESSES LAYER BODY
CAN TIE ONTO SO THANK.
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN WORKING ON
THIS IS BEEN AN INTERESTING DEAL
WITH STILL GOT A LOT OF WORK TO
DO I THINK HE LA ALWAYS GIVES A
GREAT ROAD MAP SO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK TO.
OKAY.
WHAT ALL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AT
FIRST I I I APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE AND?
MAYBE WE'LL HEAR LATER ON FROM
THE ADULT EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
FIELD BUT THEY THINK ABOUT THIS
MAY BE THE.
SOME OF THE EDUCATION GROUPS TO
YOU AS FAR AS THAT THE
CREDENTIAL ELEMENT AS WELL SO I
THINK THEY'RE WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION WILL CERTAINLY.
EVALUATE THEM.
THAT I I MET CURIOUS ABOUT THE.
THE ELIMINATING THE FEES THAT'S
INTRIGUING TO ME AND JUST WONDER
IF THERE'S A AT.
.
AND ALSO AS FAR AS HOW MUCH THAT
WOULD COST.
SHOULD WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
WE ACTUALLY. DID DIE AN
ESTIMATE.
I.
I CAN.
FIND WRONG I CAN GET BACK TO BUT
IT WAS SOMETHING LIKE FORTY TO
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS ARE
CURRENTLY.
COLLECTED IN FEES FOR CT
PROGRAMS
SO IF IF.
IF THERE IS NO LONGER A CHARGE.
FOR THOSE YOU ORDER THE GOLD
THAT HE'S A SKIT ISSUES ME SO I
DON'T ADD CT  GOTCHA YET
YEAH IDOL THAT CITY THERE'S
COULDN'T CURRENTLY THE STATE
DOES NOT. ALLOW ADULT SCHOOLS TO
CHARGE YES STUDENTS FOR ANY SL
INABILITY THAT GETS RIGHT.
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE
OUGHT TO CONSIDER IS NOT A
TIENEN THOUGH TOTALITY OF THE
WHOLE CLUB PROGRAM. MAYBE THAT'S
AN IMPEDIMENT MAYBE IT'S NOT.
AMOUNT SO INTERESTED ON THE
WHOLE NOTION WITH.
INFORMATION IDENTIFIERS AND
CERTAINLY WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS AND SO I'M
WONDERING HOW THAT'S WORKING NOW
ESPECIALLY.
WE'VE HEARD LAST YEAR WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION PEOPLE ARE
SOMETIMES LESS LIKELY TO GIVE
INFORMATION SELF.
PACK DOT CURIOUS ABOUT THAT BUT
THE OVERALL THING LA AS MR
CHáVEZ. YOU KNOW ALLUDED TO
ADULT THAT'S A GREAT PROGRAM A
BIG SUPPORTER I'D. LITERALLY
PARTICIPATE IN IT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO TO GET MY.
I SCHOOL DIPLOMA SELDON HAVE
SOUGHT FIRST HAND I'M I I DID
NOTE THAT.
.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS THAT WE WE
ARE APPROPRIATION BEFORE THE
RECESSION WAS WAS HIGHER IT WAS
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT YEAH YEAH SO WE'RE
BACK OUT OF OUR LIVES HUNDRED
AND SO I THINK THAT'S BEEN A BIG
RELIEF AND. AND I I AM STILL
WONDERING IF THERE'S IF WHAT
THE.
.
THE DEMAND IS OUT THERE IF WE
ARE. FILLING ALL THE NEEDS AND I
KNOW WE HAVE THAT THE THE COLA
IN HERE BUT IS THAT ENOUGH.
.
SO I WANT TO CONTINUE TO ASK
THAT CAN PASS THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR HER OTHER STATE TO
COME BACK AND TELL US IF THAT'S
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OR IF WE
NEED TO LOOK ABOUT.
I'VE GOING GREATER AND AND ALSO
JUST BACK TO THAT TO THE BENEFIT
OF ADULT THAT.
YOU KNOW SOME THINGS YOU CAN'T
ALWAYS QUANTIFY LET'S SAY
SOMEBODY GOES FROM A. THIRD
GRADE READING LEVEL TO A SEVENTH
GRADE IS THAT A CERTIFICATE.
NOW.
BUT IS IT A TREMENDOUS UPSIDE IN
IT AND THE SUCCESS HELPING.
PEOPLE I GET BETTER SKILLS TO BE
A THAT YOU KNOW MORE EFFECTIVE.
CITIZEN IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THEIR FAMILIES TO HELP IN THEIR
KIDS WITH THEIR HOMEWORK IN
SCHOOL. WITH EMPLOYMENT SO.
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT THE
NUMBERS AS FAR AS. HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMAS AND AND AND AND JOBS
AND AND.
MOVING ON OUR PART AS WELL BUT
THE OVERALL.
THAT MEANING OF ADULT ED IN
CALIFORNIA IS SO MUCH GREATER
AND SO I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
WE SHOULD LOSE.
A FOCUS ON THAT AT AS WELL.
.
BUT THAT THAT'S ALL FOR NOW.
ANY.
FURTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE I KNOW WILL HAVE
SOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS AND
A BIT.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION. AND
I WILL NOTE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
MOVE THE AGENDA LONG AND WE DID
HAVE A.
TWO THREE HOURS HEARING ON THIS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON. THE TV AND.
ED CAN MAYBE A FEW MONTHS AGO AS
WELL SO WHAT WE DID GO OVER A
LITTLE BIT OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSED OF THE WANTS HIM.
AND REVISIT IT TODAY AS WELL.
WE'LL START WITH.
PARTMINER FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I'M GOING TO BEGIN MY OVERVIEW
OF THE K. TWELVE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROPOSAL.
BUT BEFORE I DO THAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO POINT NINE
BILLION TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
INCLUDED IN THIS AMOUNT IS THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX MILLION FROM
THE REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
CENTERS PROGRAM WHICH WAS ROLLED
INTO THE LC FF FACE WHEN IT WAS
ENACTED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN.
IN ADDITION AN AMOUNT EQUAL TO
TWO POINT SIX PERCENT OF THE LC
EFFECT BASED GRANT IS PROVIDED
THROUGH THE NINE FOR TWELFTH
RATES BEEN ADJUSTMENT. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE HIGHER COST OF
PROVIDING CT PROGRAMS AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
ASSUMING FULL IMPLEMENTATION AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS BASE
CREDIT JUST MET WILL AMOUNT TO
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION IN ONGOING
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN BUILT IN.
TO THE LC FF BASE THAT CAN BE
USED TO SUPPORT ROBUST CTE
PROGRAMS TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY
ARE LOCAL PRIORITY.
FUNDING ALLOCATED THROUGH THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
SHOULD PAY FOR A FULL RANGE OF
EDUCATIONAL COSTS INCLUDING
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
HOWEVER AND RECOGNITION OF THE
FACT THAT HIGH QUALITY CTE
PROGRAMS PLAY A VALUABLE ROLE IN
PREPARING STUDENTS TO MEET THE
STATE LABOR MARKET DEMANDS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED MILLION AN ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
TO ESTABLISH A K. TWELVE
SPECIFIC COMPONENT WITHIN THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
THIS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO OFFER HIGH QUALITY
CT PROGRAMS. THAT ARE ALIGNED
WITH NEEDED INDUSTRY SKILLS AND
REGIONAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS OCCURRING THROUGH THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
FUNDING IS PROVIDED THROUGHT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHO WILL THEN
ALLOCATE THE FUNDING TO THE
EIGHT EXISTING STRONG WORKFORCE
REGIONAL CONSORTIA. BASED ON A
FORMULA THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE REGION'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
PROJECTED JOB OPENINGS AND SEVEN
FOR TWELVE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE.
FUNDING WILL BE ALLOCATED
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE PROCESS
WITH GRANT DETERMINATIONS BEING
MADE BY A COMMITTEE OF K. TWELVE
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EXPERTS IN EACH
REGION.
SIMILAR TO THE CT INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO EACH CONSORTIUM
WILL BE SEPARATED INTO THREE
POTS FOR SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE
APPLICANTS BASED ON THEIR
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE.
IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING APPLICANTS MUST BE A
MEMBER OF THE CONSORTIUM AND BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE REGIONAL
EFFORTS TO LINE WORKFORCE
EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATION
SERVICES.
THEY MUST UTILIZE THE REGION'S
PLAN TO INFORM THEIR EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT OR EXPAND UPON CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION COURSES THAT
THEY ARE OFFERING.
THE MUST PROVIDE A LOCAL MATCH
FOR ANY FUNDING RECEIVED FROM
THE PROGRAM. AND THEY MUST MEET
CERTAIN MINIMUM ELIGIBILITY
STANDARDS THE MAJORITY OF WHICH
ARE LIFTED FROM THE EXISTING
CITY INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES TWELVE MILLION AND
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
TO PUT IN PLACE A REGIONAL
LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE TO ASSESS
TEACHERS AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS
IN IMPLEMENTING HIGH QUALITY C.
T. PROGRAMS.
NOW THAT I PREFER COVERED WHAT
THE PROPOSAL IS I'D LIKE TO TAKE
A FEW MINUTES TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE MISINFORMATION THAT HAS COME
UP IN CONVERSATION SO WE PACKED
WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
PROCESS FUNDING TO THE REGIONAL
CONSORTIUMS THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE LINE ITEM.
THE PROPOSAL IS TO FIND A NICE
WAY TO UTILIZE THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE INCLUDING THE EXISTING
FISCAL AGENTS.
VETERAN PLACE FOR THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
IT IS NOT STRUCTURED THIS WAY TO
SIGNAL THAT THE K. TWELVE
COMPONENT OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAM.
NOR WILL COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BE ABLE
TO ACT ALLOCATE BURKE THE ABLE
TO RECEIVE ANY OF THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED FOR THE PROGRAM.
SECONDLY WE'VE HEARD OUR
PROPOSAL CHARACTERIZED AS A
SHIFT OF K. TWELVE CT TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS AN ACCURATE
FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
BUT THE T. INFANT OF GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
EXPIRES AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
IT WAS DESIGNED TO BE A SHORT
TERM TRANSITION PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO INVEST IN CT. DURING
THE FACE SOME OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS ALWAYS
MATCHES THE PROGRAM AS SUCH.
THE GOVERNOR IS NOT SHIFTING
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS PROGRAM
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
RATHER THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO ESTABLISH A NEW
PROGRAM THAT'S NARROWLY TAILORED
TO INCENTIVIZE ELEAZAR TO
IMPLEMENT OR EXPAND UPON
REGIONALLY ALIGNED. CD
PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ADMINISTER AN OVERSEE SEVERAL K.
TWELVE CD PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES
AGRICULTURAL INCENTIVE GRANTS
SPECIALIZED SECONDARY PROGRAMS
IN THE CITY PATHWAYS PROGRAM.
THIRD WE'VE HEARD THAT THE
WORKFORCE PATHWAY COORDINATORS
HAVE BEEN LABELED AS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES EMPLOYEES.
THE REFERENCE AND TRAILER BILL
TO ESTABLISHING ONE PER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WAS
FOR GEOGRAPHIC PURPOSES ONLY.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WOULD
APPLY TO SERVE IN THIS CAPACITY.
INDUSTRY PARTNERS COULD ALSO
SERVE AS FOR ALL TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE PARTNERING WITH THE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY.
ULTIMATELY IT'S THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WHO'LL BE THE ONE
SELECTING THE INDIVIDUALS TO
SERVE IN THIS FOR ALL.
IN ADDITION SOME HAVE THOUGHT
THAT ALL SEVENTY TWO WORKFORCE
PATHWAY COORDINATORS WOULD BE
BASED HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WE PLACED OUT
IN THE FIELD ENSURING THAT THERE
ACCESSIBLE TO ELOISE AND THEIR
SERVICE AREA.
FINALLY WE'VE HEARD CONCERN THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON INDUSTRY
ALIGNMENT. MEANS THAT CITY
PROGRAMS FUNDED THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM. FOR IT THROUGH THE
PROPOSAL WOULD NOT BE ALIGNED TO
CT STANDARDS
OR WOULD BE COMPLETELY VOID OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ENGAGEMENT IT CAREER
EXPLORATION.
WE AGREE THAT STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
A CAREER EXPLORATION ARE WORTH
YOU SEE T. EQUALS
WHICH IS WHY THE MINIMUM
ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS. CALLED
OUT IN THE PROPOSAL'S TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRE THAT
APPLICANTS FOR THEIR SAFETY
PROGRAMS OFFER HIGH QUALITY
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTION.
ALIGNED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION MODEL
CURRICULUM STANDARDS.
PROVIDE PEOPLE'S WITH QUALITY
CAREER EXPLORATION GUIDANCE.
AND PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN INTER
CHECKS
COMPETITION AND OTHER WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE END OF THE
TABLE TO TALK ABOUT HOW HE'S
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM
BENEFITS KICK OFF.
MORNING CARE MCCARTY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M ALSO WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE MALIK WAS WORTH.
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE SOME
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED
AND WHY THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT IT'S THE PROPER
VENUE. FOR CONTINUING TO SUPPORT
K. THROUGH TWELVE CD PROGRAMS.
THAT FOCUS ON PROVIDING TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION SERVES A
VARIETY PURPOSES TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AS THEY BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT TO DO WHEN
THEY GROW UP.
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA PROVIDES HIGH SCHOOLS
WITH ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE TO OFFER CTT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NOT NECESSARILY ALIGNED
WITH REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS.
BUT SUPPORT DIFFERENT GOALS.
PROPOSAL THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PUT FORTH IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
FOCUSES ON ONE PARTICULAR
PURPOSE AND GOAL. TO PROVIDE CT
TRAINING PROGRAMS ALIGNS
WITH REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS TO
ENSURE THAT ONE STUDENTS
COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. THERE WILL BE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES WAITING FOR THEM
IN THEIR CHOSEN FIELD OF STUDY.
RESEARCH IN THIS AREA SHOWS THAT
HAVING A CERTIFICATE OR AN
INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED CREDENTIAL
LEADS TO HIGHER PAYING MIDDLE
SKILL JOBS.
A STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
IN RESPONSE TO RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BOARD OF GOVERNOR'S
TASK FORCE ON WORKFORCE JOB
CREATION AND A STRONG ECONOMY.
THE TASK FORCE IDENTIFIED AN
OPPORTUNITY THEY THAT EXISTED TO
ALIGN THE MARRIOTT OF TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. OFFERED AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES.
WITH THE STATE'S REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
BUILD UPON THESE ALIGNMENT
EFFORTS ALREADY TAKING PLACE.
THE PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY FUNDED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THIS FUNDING WAS
INCREASED TO FORTY EIGHT TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION.
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ESTABLISHED
REGIONAL CONSORTIA IN EIGHT
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS
ACROSS THE STRAIT STATE.
TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP IN
COORDINATING PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTING CAREER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN EACH REGION.
STATUTE REQUIRES EACH CONSORTIUM
TO DEVELOP A FOUR YEAR PLAN
UPDATED ANNUALLY AND IT'S POSTED
ON THE PUBLIC STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM WEBSITE.
PLANS ADDRESS THE FOLLOWING FOUR
QUESTIONS.
WHAT ARE THE PRIORITY AND
EMERGING SECTORS IN EACH REGION?
WHAT MORE MUST BE DONE TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS OTHERS AS THEY
PROGRESS THROUGH THE CAREER
PATHWAYS IN THE IDENTIFIED
INDUSTRY SECTORS?
HOW WILL JOB PLACEMENT
INTERNSHIPS AND REGIONAL
INDUSTRY ENGAGEMENT BE
COORDINATED?
AND FOURTH HOW CAN INDUSTRY
INFORMED AND CO INVEST IN CT
DEVELOPMENT AND THE
COLLEGES.
WE BELIEVE THE SAME QUESTIONS
APPLY TO CT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING OFFERED AT THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE LEVEL.
EACH REGIONAL CONSORTIUM REPORTS
THEIR OUTCOME DATA TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
DISAGGREGATED BY RACE GENDER AND
AGE.
THIS INFORMATION IS POSTED ON
THE LAUNCH BOARD DATA SYSTEM A
TOOL SUPPORTED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THAT ALLOWS
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
REGIONAL CONSORTIA PARTNERS TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM CT
INVESTMENTS.
WITHIN EACH STRONG WORKFORCE
CONSORTIUM A DEPUTY SECTOR
NAVIGATOR HAS BEEN SELECTED FOR
EACH OF THE INDUSTRY SECTORS
PRIORITIZE NOT CONSORTIUMS PLAN.
THE DEPUTY SECTOR NAVIGATOR
WORKS WITH REGIONAL COLLEGES AND
EMPLOYERS IN THE AREA TO
DETERMINE THE WORKFORCE TRAINING
NEEDS FOR THAT INDUSTRY. AND TO
DEVELOP HERE CAREER PATHWAYS AND
THE ASSOCIATED CURRICULUM. THAT
THEY WILL PROVIDE STUDENTS SO
THEY HAVE THE SKILLS NEEDED TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN THESE JOBS.
THE WORKFORCE PATHWAY
COORDINATORS THAT ARE PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S QUE PROVE
TWELVE CD.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD WORK CLOSELY
WITH EACH CONSORTIUMS DEPUTY
SECTOR NAVIGATORS.
EVERY STRONG WORKFORCE
CONSORTIUM HAS A DESIGNATED QUE
THROUGH FOURTEEN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER WHO SUPPORTS
THE DEVELOPMENT AND ARTICULATION
OF CAREER PATHWAYS BETWEEN K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THESE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS WERE INITIALLY FUNDED
WITH S. B. TEN SEVENTY CT
PATHWAYS PROGRAM DOLLARS. BUT
THIS SOURCE OF FUNDING IS
EXPIRING AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
MANY CONSORTIA HOWEVER I
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT WORK
BEING DONE BY EACH OF THESE CASE
THROUGH FOURTEEN ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS.
AND THEY ARE ALLOCATING SOME OF
THEIR STRONG WORKFORCE DOLLARS
TO CONTINUE THE WORK OF THE
ESCAPE ROUTE.
FOURTEEN.
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS.
THE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM HAS
STARTED SHOWING SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS AS
DOCUMENTED ON THE LAUNCH FOR
DATA SYSTEM.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE LAUNCHED THE
STRONG WORKFORCE STARS PROGRAM.
TO RECOGNIZE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CT PROGRAMS THAT SHOWN PROVEN
GAINES AND HELPING STUDENTS
INCREASE THEIR EARNING POWER AND
SOCIAL MOBILITY.
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED CT
PROGRAMS OFFERED AT SIXTY FIVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE EARNED
ONE OR MORE STARS. BY SHOWING
DATA DRIVEN IMPROVEMENTS IN
THREE AREAS A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN EARNINGS ATTAINMENT
OF A LIVING WAGE AND FINDING A
JOB THAT'S CLOSELY MATCHED WITH
THEIR FIELD OF STUDY.
ANALYSIS HAS SHOWN THAT ONE OF
THE COMMON FACTORS OF CTE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE RECEIVED THE
STRONG WORKFORCE STAR
DESIGNATION IS INTER SEGMENTAL
PARTICIPATION AND PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT INCLUDES STRATEGIES LIKE
DOLE ENROLLMENT AND ARTICULATION
AGREEMENTS THAT HELP JUMPSTART
STUDENTS CAREER EXPLORATION AND
PREPARATION WHILE THEY'RE STILL
ENROLLED IN HIGH SCHOOL.
EVER SIX POINT FOUR MILLION OF
THE STRONG WORKFORCE FUNDING
PROVIDED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WAS SPENT WHAT
PROJECTS THAT SUPPORT QUE
THROUGH TWELVE CTD ACTIVITIES.
FOR EXAMPLE MANY STRONG WORSE
CONSORTIUM OR SPENDING FUNDS TO
PROVIDE THE GET FOCUSED STAY
FOCUSED PROGRAM TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE CAREER
EXPLORATION AND GUIDANCE COURSE.
MANY COLLEGES ARE ALSO OFFERING
THE GET FOCUS STAY FOCUSED
PROGRAM TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
THROUGH DOLAN ROMAN. THE PROGRAM
IS REACHING ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT SCHOOLS STATEWIDE.
AND TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE
RECEIVING DOLAN MOMENT CREDIT.
IT'S FINANCIALLY BENEFITS BOTH
THE COLLEGES AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
ANOTHER STRONG MORSE WORKFORCE
PROJECT THAT HAS RECEIVED
RECOGNITION IS THE IT'S RAINING
JOBS
SUMMIT PUT ON BY THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND MOTHER LODE
CONSORTIUM TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR HIGH SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNSELORS
TO LEARN FROM INDUSTRY EXPERTS
ABOUT THE EDUCATION AND SKILL
REQUIREMENTS FOR HIGH DEMAND
JOBS IN THE REGION.
THE GOAL WAS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELORS TO BE WELL INFORMED
AND EQUIPPED TO ADVISE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ABOUT MIDDLE
SKILLS CAREERS. THAT WERE
OFFERED AT THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AS NOTED MANY STRONG WORST
STRONG WORKFORCE CONSORTIA ARE
ALREADY SUPPORTING A LINE CTE
PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES OFFERED
AT K. THROUGH TWELVE ELEAZAR.
AND MANY SOLID WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CREATED.
OUR PROPOSAL EXPANDS ON THESE
EFFORTS WITH THE GOAL OF HELPING
STUDENTS MAKE WISE AND INFORMED
DECISIONS AS THEY BEGIN TO PLAN
THEIR CAREERS WHILE IN HIGH
SCHOOL. SO ONCE THEY COMPLETE
THEIR PROGRAMS THEY WILL OF
LEARN THE SKILLS THAT EMPLOYERS
ARE LOOKING FOR AND BE WELL
PREPARED TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STATE'S WORKFORCE NEEDS.
WITH THAT I'M HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND KEEP.
THANK YOU RYAN ANDERSON
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IS
THAT CHAIR NOTED OUR OFFICE AND
GAVE A BROADER PRESENTATION ON
CT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALON
OUR CONCERNS WITH THAT PROPOSAL
AT AN EARLIER HEARING SO. RATHER
THAN REPEAT ALL THOSE POINTS I'M
JUST GOING TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS A
THE.
TWO ALTERNATIVES THAT WE'VE.
PUT FORWARD AND HOW THOSE
ALTERNATIVES WOULD ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. SO
THE FIRST IS THAT WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE THE STATE FUNDS CTE
THROUGH THE LCF APPROACH WE
THINK THIS HAS.
NUMEROUS ADVANTAGES OVER THE
CATEGORICAL APPROACH BUT
PRIMARILY WE THINK IT EMPHASIZES
THAT CT IS PART OF THE CORE
ACADEMIC CURRICULUM. OF A HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION
A.
SO RATHER THAN DISTRICTS BEING
CONCERNED WITH OUR WE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN A CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM AND.
ARE WE MEETING THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS OF OF THAT PROGRAM
THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
THEIR OBLIGATION IS NOT LIMITED
JUST TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF THAT
SPECIFIC PROGRAM. NOW THEY'RE IN
THERE MIGHT BE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE LC FF APPROACH FOR
EXAMPLE.
IT IS ZOOMS THAT DISTRICTS ARE
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR.
ACTUALLY PROVIDING APPROPRIATE
CT FOR THE THIRD STUDENTS
THAT STATE ONLY RECENTLY
INTRODUCED ITS COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS INDICATOR BUT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD. MODIFIER
STRENGTHENED THAT IF IT WAS
CONCERNED WITH ACCOUNTABILITY.
O. ALTERNATIVELY IF THE.
LEGISLATURE WERE CONCERNED THAT
NOT ENOUGH FUNDING WERE
AVAILABLE IT COULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL BOMP.
TO THE HIGH SCHOOL EL CFF BASE
RATE.
NOW IF THE LEGISLATURE WERE
INTERESTED IN FUNDING CT USING A
CATEGORICAL APPROACH WE DO THINK
THAT THE EXISTING CD INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM HAS. OF SEVERAL
ADVANTAGES OVER AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A IN
PARTICULAR IT OFFERS MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR A SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE. A CD PATHWAYS THAT
MIGHT NOT BE ALIGNED WITH THEIR
REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS BUT.
REGARDLESS OFFER BENEFITS.
AT SUCH AS STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
BUT WE ALSO THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOESN'T
PROPERLY LEVERAGE THE EXISTING
EXPERTISE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
IT.
EDUCATION AND SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNING AND SUPPORTING HIGH
SCHOOL CT PROGRAMS.
WE DO THINK THAT THE THE CT
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM COULD BE
IMPROVED UPON ITS CURRENT
DESIGN.
IT FOR INSTANCE COULD.
BE MODIFIED TO INCLUDE.
INDEED FOR EXISTING CATEGORICAL
CT PROGRAMS THAT OF REMAIN
OUTSIDE OF.
BOTH THE INCENTIVE GRANT AND VLC
FF APPROACH IT AND CONTRIBUTE TO
SORT OF A SPLINTERED APPROACH TO
CT EDUCATION IN THE STATE. AYE A
COULD BE MODIFIED TO REQUIRE
BETTER COORDINATION INCLUDING
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES A IN
A COULD BE WRITTEN A MODIFIED TO
REQUIRE THAT SOME. A PROPORTION
OF THOSE FUNDS BE USED IN
ALIGNMENT WITH REGIONAL
WORKFORCE.
MEANS AND THAT'S ALL FOR MY
COMMENTS WRITTEN.
OKAY.
DEBORAH VENABLE HAVE A STATE TO
PRETEND IN A PUBLIC INSTRUCTION
TOM PUBLIC SENTIMENT SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT ICT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AND I THINK
ALSO TALK ABOUT. SORT OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THAT PROGRAM AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THE WITH
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT TO SHOW
THAT IT DOES WARRANT.
FURTHER AND CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN CT EASE SO WHAT WE
AT THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
JUST TO PROVE THE FINAL ROUND
OF.
AND OF GRANTEES OF THAT WAS
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX GRANT
RECIPIENTS AND WILL NOTE THAT AS
AS WE GAUGE INTEREST BECAUSE
THIS DOES REQUIRE A MATCH THAT
WAS NEARLY A BILLIONDOLLARS IN
LOCAL MATCHES THAT AT LEAST HAD
PLEDGED TO PROVIDE SO. I THINK
THAT SPEAKS TO THE INTERESTED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO TO PROVIDING
HIGH QUALITY DCT  PROGRAMS
WE'VE ALSO SEEN OVER THAT THE
COURSE OF THE CT PROGRAM AND TO
THE LEFT AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TWELVE. AT A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
ENROLLMENT NCTE PROGRAMS ARE
CURRENTLY FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED IN TT  PROGRAMS.
THE INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT SHOW
THE LARGEST GROWTH ARE
INFORMATION COMMUNICATIONS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND MANUFACTURING
ENGINEERING HOSPITALITY AND
TOURISM AND PUBLIC SERVICES. I'M
UNDER THAT SEATED PROGRAM
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PUT IT
CREATE AND EXPAND PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE DRIVEN BY STUDENT
INTEREST AT CURRENT REGIONALIST
IT WAIT LABOR MARKET DATA
INTEREST INDUSTRY ADVOCACY
INVOLVEMENT AND ALIGNMENT WITH
PROGRAMS OFFERED AT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
I WILL SAY THAT THAT KATO CTE
PROGRAM IS UNIQUE FROM OTHER
FROM THE C. T. PROGRAMS IN THAT
IT IS INTEGRATED WITH THE CT
. MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS AND ALSO INCLUDES THAT
CAREER TECHNICAL A STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND TO IN
LEADERSHIPS BANG INTERPOL TO
THAT THE CD COURSEOBJECTIVES
AND STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH
THE CONTINUUM OF WORK WORK BASED
LEARNING EXPERIENCES THROUGHOUT
THEIR CTE COURSE SEQUENCES.
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE C. TAKE
FUNDS WERE USED TO BRING CT
PROGRAMS UP TO THE CURRENT
INDUSTRY STANDARDS AND EQUIPMENT
AND WITH CAPITAL OUTLAY DOLLARS
BEING USED FOR A VARIETY OF
STATE OF THE ART EQUIPMENT.
BUT MOST OF THE PROGRAM'S THIS
WAS THE FIRST SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS EQUIPMENT SINCE THEY
RECESSION IMPACTED INVESTMENTS
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN SO THAT WAS
REALLY IN THE FIRST. COUPLE
YEARS OF THE FUNDING AT THE
SEATED FUNDS WERE ALSO USED TO
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR CT TEACHERS AND CITY LEADERS
AND COUNSELORS.
WELL ALSO NOTE THAT THAT THE
SEATED MONEY TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS AND SEVEN COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION. AND SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO HELP UP PROGRAMS WITH
THEIR CT MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS THE INTEGRATION OF THE
K. TWELVE GENERAL EDUCATION
COURSEWORK SO WE WILL REALLY ARE
SAYING I'M. GREATER INTEGRATION
OF CD PROGRAMS WITHIN THAT.
AT HIGH SCHOOL CURRICULUM AND
ALSO THE CAREER STE THAT STUDENT
LEADERSHIP ORGANIZATIONS AND
CURRENT COLLEGE PATHWAYS
DEVELOPMENTS.
I'M IN ADDITION TO THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDED BY THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSESSMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY DIVISIONS TO
PROVIDE. STATEWIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON UPGRADES TO CAL
PADS AS WELL AS TRAININGS ON THE
PERKINS GRANT MANAGEMENT WITH.
THE STAFF THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY.
AND WE'VE ALSO COLLABORATED WITH
AT THE FACILITIES TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS THROUGH THE CT
FACILITIES PROGRAM APPLICATION
AND PROVIDE A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. TO NEW CT LEADERS
TO RCT INSTITUTE.
OVERNIGHT AND THEN WE AT AM I
THINK AS WE LOOK AHEAD WE'RE
LOOKING AT PRIORITIZING CT
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL EXPANSION THEIR
PILOT GRANT PROGRAM FOR TEN.
MIDDLE SCHOOL CT PROGRAMS THAT
ALIGN TO CALIFORNIA'S
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES AND
WORKING WITH THREE TO FOUR TO
PLAN FURTHER EXPANSIONS.
WE'RE ALSO HAPPY WITH THE FOR
THE PLEASED WITH THE PROGRESS OF
THE FOUR HUNDRED CALIPHATE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
ACADEMIES.
AND PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THAT USE CONTINUE TO REMAIN A
HIGH PRIORITY.
AND I THINK WITHOUT WOULD JUST
SPEAKING TO IT TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAMS AND REALLY
CONTINUED INVESTMENT AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORTS
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. INCLUDING
THE LEGISLATION CARRIED BY
MISTER O'DONNELL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE SOME ON GOING MONEY FOR
CT. THINK YOU OWE ANY SHOULD ADD
AS HAVE DONNA Y. IT HERE AGAIN
WITH THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
TRANSITIONS DIVISION TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
OKAY COMMITTEE BECAUSE. THEY Q.
KRISHNASWAMY WITH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS TO MAKE CLEAR WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT A LINE EFFORTS
ACROSS SYSTEMS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE COMMITMENTS
WE'VE MADE IN OUR VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
AND WE THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ONE
REASONABLE WAY OF DOING THAT I
DO WANT TO NOTE THE SIGNIFICANT
ACTIVITY THAT GOES ON ALREADY.
BETWEEN OURS BETWEEN SCHOOLS IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE MANY
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ALREADY PARTICIPATED IN A STRONG
WORK FIRST PROGRAM IN MANY
REGIONS. AND MEMBERS OF OUR
BOARD OF GOVERNORS PARTICIPATE
IN THE WORKFORCE PATHWAYS JOINT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION SO SOME OF THAT WORK.
YOU KNOW IS ALREADY HAPPENING
SO. WE'RE HERE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR LEAD ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS ARE ALL START OFF THE
ICE WHEN ASKED START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO I I I
HEAR YOU SAY THEY
SUPERINTENDENT.
ENDORSES THE PROPOSAL.
PUT FORTH BY A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATORS NOT ONLY IN THE BILL
BUT IN THIS SUBCOMMITTEE WELLTO.
GO UP TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
AND SO IN ADDITION ARE YOU ARE
YOU RECOMMENDING THAT THE THAT
THE PROGRAM STAY. WITHIN THE.
A DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION LIKE
WE HAVE BEEN DOING AT THE PAST.
THREE YEARS.
I THINK WHAT WE WOODS WHAT WE
WOULD SAY THAT THAT IS REALLY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
FOCUSING ON MAINTAINING THIS YES
YES OR NO.
I THINK GOOD SAY YES WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE IT IT WE'D LIKE TO
MAINTAIN THE PROGRAM COMMENDED
YEAH STANDARDS YET OKAY IT'S ONE
OF DID CLARIFY THAT FOR THE
RECORD. I WITH THAT YOU KNOW WE
WE HAD A LENGTHY HEARING ABOUT
THIS.
A FEW MONTHS AGO SO I WON'T GET
BACK INTO ALL THE DETAILS BUT.
I SUPPORT THAT I KEEP IN THE THE
AMOUNTS.
WAY NORTH OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WE WANT TO START AT
FOUR START THREE AND WENT DOWN
INTO THE NOTION WAS ALL THAT
DISTRICTS WILL THEY'LL CONTINUE
TO FUND THIS BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
HIGH PRIORITY BUT.
AS WE HEARD FROM.
A HEARING TWO WEEKS AGO LCF
AFTER SO MANY OTHER NEEDS THAT I
THINK THAT'S FANTASY LAND
THINKING THAT THEY WILL FUND
THESE PROGRAMS AT THAT HIGH
LEVEL AND CONTINUE WITH THE NEED
TO DO.
ON TO SKATE FOR FUNDING IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND SO THAT SUCH A
HIGH PRIORITY I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE.
AT SPECIFIC CATEGORICAL UP ON
THIS ON THE AYE SUPPORTS AND A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION MORE THAN
WHAT'S IN THERE NOW I THINK THAT
THAT BOOK TALKING ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THAT PENDING
ON.
HOW REVENUES COME IN THE MAY
REVISE SIR LOOK AND SHIFTING
THINGS AROUND?
AYE I DO YOU ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THAT WE SEE IT BEFORE BUT I
THINK THIS SUBCOMMITTEE AND I'D
SUPPORT.
FINDING IT IN THE CD WHEN I
THINK THAT'LL BE THE ACTION OF
THIS SIZE SUBCOMMITTEE WE WE
DON'T.
SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATION TO
PUT IN THE COMMUNICABLE GE'S.
AND.
THINK THAT THAT SIMPLE THAT.
MR MARTZ RITCHIE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I GO.
WANT TO.
REINFORCE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
ABOUT TO.
WHAT I'VE SEEN AND IN IN MY
DISTRICT IN TERMS OF?
THESE.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE ARE CAME THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS. BEING SO
STRAPPED FOR MONEY THAT.
YOU KNOW WHILE THEY WOULD LOVE
TO ME CT MORE PRIORITY.
THEY HAVE TO PAY THEIR TEACHERS
FIRST AND THEN THEY HAVE TO.
THE THEY HAVE TO BALANCE THEIR
OWN BUDGETS AND SO YOU KNOW THEY
DID THE READ THE. THE THE IDEAL
IS IS IT'S NOT.
BEING.
CARRIED OUT IN THE REAL WORLD.
BUT MY CONCERN YOU KNOW I I
WONDER. HEAR FURTHER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND AND
AND TO SEE IF A. BALLET O..
CAN DOWN.
HAD FURTHER PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
SPENT.
WHAT WHAT I SEE HAPPENING IN MY
DISTRICT IS IS THAT YOU KNOW
NUMBER ONE A AS?
I'VE I'VE TALKED OFTEN BEFORE
WE HAVE A WONDERFUL RE.
YOU JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT
REGIONAL OCCUPATION CENTER
PROGRAM TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL CENTER.
.
BUT INCREASINGLY WITH THE.
CT INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM I AM
SEEING OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN.
CT PROGRAMS LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE OVER THE.
FAR RECESS I I VISITED THERE.
TWO HIGH SCHOOLS IN TORRANCE
NORTH HIGH SCHOOL IN TORRANCE
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN THEY BOTH
HAD THEIR OWN. AEROSPACE
ENGINEERING CLASSES AND.
.
AND AND YOU KNOW THE USED
EQUIPMENT TIP TO PURCHASE THIS
WIND TUNNEL ON THEIR DESIGNING
WINGS AND AND
AND AND AND THEY HAVE LIKE A
THREE D..
.
THE A DESIGNING SOFTWARE AND
THAT THERE ARE DESIGNING.
.
YOU KNOW AIR AIRPLANES AND AND
AND.
OTHER AEROSPACE EQUIPMENT.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT STRUCK ME WAS
THATIT IT IT IT LOOKED GREAT.
WITH THESE PROGRAMS BEING
OFFERED TO THEIR OWN STUDENTS AT
NORTH HIGH SCHOOL AND HAVE
TORRANCE HIGH SCHOOL.
BUT IT IT WAS GOING THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IN TERMS OF THIS.
REGIONALIZATION YOU KNOW BECAUSE
IT'S IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT IT
JUST MAKES COMMON SENSE. THAT
STUDENTS NORTH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WILL TAKE CLASSES AT
NORTH HIGH SCHOOL AND TORRANCE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO TAKE
CLASSES THAT TORRANCE HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS RITA
REGIONAL CONSORTIUM IDEA IN A
WHILE IT SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE
THEY YOU ALIGN ALL THE. BE THERE
THAT THE.
THE INDUSTRY NEEDS A AT A
REGIONAL LEVEL AND AND AND YOU
ALIGN THESE PROGRAMS AND YOU
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF DUAL
ENROLLMENT AND SO FORTH. BUT
IT'S IT SEEMS LIKE.
THAT GOES AGAINST SOME OF THE
BASIC REALITIES OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS
THAT THEY'RE GONNA STAY. WERE
WHAT'S OF TWO WORDS BUT FAMILIAR
TO THEM
AND ELECTED A SKIT AND THEY'RE
GONNA THEY'RE GONNA TRY TO STAY
AT THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS IN AND SO
TO ME.
YOU KNOW. I I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THE THIS REGIONAL CONSORTIUM
IDEA. WOULD.
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE REALITY
OF OUR MOST STUDENTS WOULD WANNA
GO TO WHAT'S MOST CONVENIENT AND
WAS MOST FAMILIAR TO THEM WHICH
IS STAYING AT THEIR OWN SCHOOLS
AND TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF. OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED THROUGH. THE.
THE CDC TECH PROGRAM AYE GUIDE
LIKE TO HEAR THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES.
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THE MEAN OUT
OUT.
GO FIRST ON THIS BUT I THINK THE
IDEA.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THERE IS THERE
TO DIFFERENT HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE
TORRANCE AREA AND THAT ARE
OFFERING THE SAME PROGRAM RIGHT
I WOULD THINK. YOU KNOW
AERONAUTICAL DESIGN AND WHATEVER
WOULD BE VERY EXTENSIVE BURKE OR
EXPENSIVE IN TERMS OF THE KIND
EQUIPMENT THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
BEEN WHAT THAT.
.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE FOR. ONE OF THOSE HIGH
SCHOOLS
TO OFFER THIS PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD BE YOU KNOW IN PART
FUNDED THROUGH THE THE
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN THE STRONG WORK FORCE. AND
THEN SIMILAR TO DUAL ENROLLMENT
MORE YOU HAVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS GOING TO THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO TAKE THE COURTS THERE AND
THEY ACTUALLY GET HIGH SCHOOL
PREDICT FOR THOSE COURSES. YOU
COULD HAVE STUDENTS TAKING
THESE.
AERONAUTICAL TRAINING COURSES
THAT THIS ONE HIGH SCHOOL RATHER
THAN HAVING BOTH SCHOOLS
SPEND THEIR MONEY ON THE SAME
PROGRAM. YET SO I KNOW THAT THAT
IS THE IDEAL THAT YOUR YOUR.
YOUR.
.
BASING YOUR PROPOSAL ON THAT
BUT I'M SAYING THAT THAT GOES
AGAINST THE REALITY OF STUDENTS
WHO WANT TO STAY AT THEIR OWN
SCHOOLS.
AND SO WHILE THEM IT MAY NOT BE
THE MOST.
FINANCIALLY FISH AND I THINK
THAT'S AN ARGUMENT FOR. THE ARE
OCP THAT THEY HAVE THE.
.
THE CAPITAL INTENSIVE.
A CT PROGRAMS.
BROUGH PROVIDED AT A REGIONAL
LEVEL BUT I I AM JUST SAYING
THERE THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
REALITY THAT I'M WITNESS
HERE THEY THAT SEEMS TO MAKE
SENSE TO ME THAT STUDENTS WILL.
DO WHAT IS CAN IT WAS CONVENIENT
AND AND AND FAMILIAR TO THEM
STATE THEIR OWN SCHOOL.
SO I I I JUST WANTED TO.
RATE IT YOU KNOW SHARE THAT
OBSERVATION.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO GO AGAINST
THE EFFORTS FOR REGIONALS.
AND I JUST HAD TO.
I I UNDERSTAND THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING ABOUT STUDENTS WANTING TO
STAY IN PROGRAMS AND SO EXCITING
FOR FAMILIAR TO THEM.
BUT THE REALITY TOO IS ALSO
THAT HIGH SCHOOL WAS A FOUR
YEAR.
YOU KNOW EXPERIENCE. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT THE STUDENTS HAVE
PATHWAYS TO GO INTO NON COMEDIC
COLLEGE OR CAREER AND THAT'S
REALLY THE GENESIS BEHIND THIS
PROPOSAL.
MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MY
CONCERNS I THINK THEY'VE. GIVEN
CHAIRPERSON MOTHERS TO THEY
CENTER AROUND MONEY GOVERNANCE
AND PROBABLY TODAY MORE THE
MISSION THAN EVER BEFORE IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS
OF THIS EFFORT.
NEVER ONE OF THE MONEY
APPRECIATED THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNIZING THAT THAT YOU BEYOND
GOING IT'S GREAT. AGAIN I SHARE
WITH THE CHAIR SAID IT SHOULD BE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
WHERE I AM.
BECAUSE IS VERY IMPORTANT AND WE
INVEST IN OUR STUDENTS BUT ALSO
ECONOMY IS ALSO ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. I DO
APPRECIATE THE TWELVE MILLION
FOR THE PATHWAY COORDINATORS I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING.
UNDER THE GOVERNANCE.
MY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT TURN
THIS MONEY OVER THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I STILL DON'T SEE.
WHY WE DO THIS IT SETS OR VERY
POOR PRECEDENCE?
FOR BETWEEN ECOLOGY MANAGING K.
TWELVE OPERATIONS IN SOME SENSE
ON CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
AND THEN THE CONSORTIUM.
WE HEARD SOME CONCERNS FROM THE
ADULT ED COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
CONSORTIUM MODEL. TO ME IT'S
JUST YOU KNOW THE MONEY IS GONNA
GET DOWN IT'S GONNA GO INTO
OUTER SPACETHAT'S GOING ON THE
SOVIET BLOC IT'S GONNA GET LOST.
THERE'S GONNA BE FIGHTING OVER
IT.
WHY WOULDN'T THERE BE FIGHTING
OVER
I MEAN IF YOU'RE ON THAT
CONSORTIA YOU'RE GONNA FIGHT
FEAR OF DISTRICT?
AND IF YOU'RE NOT IN AN EQUAL
PLACE I JUST.
I JUST I DON'T. TRUST THAT
MODEL.
BECAUSE I'D I I'D SAY IT'S
INHERENT THAT POLITICS WILL PLAN
TO WEAR AND IN THE INCENTIVE
GRANT. I'M PRETTY CLEAR IT'S AN
INCENTIVE GRANT OF YOU KNOW
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO EAVIS
SERRATED.
I WATCHED IT.
BEING OF HISTORY TO THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL.
WE'VE A SERRATED.
YOU KNOW.
KERR TECH LOCATIONAL EDUCATION
NOW WE HAVE TO BUILD A BACK THE
INCENTIVE IS THE BEST WAITED DO
I THINK THE INCENTIVE. MODEL
ACTUALLY BUYS INTO THE L. CFF
MODEL TO AS WELL MORE SO THAN
THAN THAN THAN THE OTHER.
CONSORTIUM MODEL.
BOB. PUT BUT GOING ON A MISSION
WITH TEN I'M HEARING TODAY'S RUN
LIKE I'M I'M HEARING OR WAS
GOING TO THE GERMAN MODEL WHERE
YOU PICK YOUR LANE IN SEVENTH
GRADE.
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE GOING
TO BE.
MET THAT WORRIES ME BECAUSE I
HEAR A LOT OF TALK ABOUT STRONG
WORKFORCE AND ALMOST. ADULTS
MORE SO THAN CHILDREN MERRILEES
OUR KIDS WE WANT THESE PROGRAMS
A MIDDLE SCHOOLS WE WANT THEM
HIGH SCHOOLS.
AND WE WANT STUDENTS TO THERE'S
A VARIETY OF PURPOSES WERE
OFFERING CT IT'S NOT JUST THAT
IN SEVENTH GRADE YOU'RE GONNA
DECIDE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE.
YOU'RE GOING ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING THAT'S WE'RE GOING
TO GO IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE YOU
KNOW STUDENTS LEARNING STEM
SKILLS STUDENTS GROWING.
STUDENTS SEEING WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES THEY MIGHT SEE AS
A FIT FOR THEM.
SO I I'D I I HOPE WE'RE NOT
TRACKING IN THE SEVENTH GRADE
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I'M HEARING
WHEN I HEAR A LOT OF THIS.
YOU KNOW HIGH LEVEL TO THE
INDUSTRY NEEDS AND THAT'S WHAT
THESE KIDS NEED TO GO WITH
THEY'RE GONNA PICK THEIR LAN WE
SHOULDN'T BE PICKING THEIR LINE
FOR THEM. SO AGAIN THE OVERALL
MISSION OF THIS EFFORT IS KIND A
GENERAL CONCERN WITH THAT TODAY
TO.
BUT.
AGAIN I I REALLY THINK THE
CONSORTIA YOU KNOW THE MONEY ON
THE CONSORTIUM'S WERE WHILE I
HAVE ONLY NEEDS TO BE MORE.
AND.
THE CONSORTIUM MODEL REALLY
SCARES ME AS TO WHAT ULTIMATELY
PLAYS OUT. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITH THAT I TURNED ABOUT I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
THAT.
I CERTAINLY LIKE TO COMMENT.
.
I JUST THINK THE WAY THE
CONSORTIA ARE STRUCTURED AND
UNSTRUCTURED NOW I'VE BEEN TO A
MEETING OF THE A REGIONAL
CONSORTIUM THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND IT WAS AMAZING THEY WERE
THEY WERE HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELORS
THERE THE RECOUP SEVERAL
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THERE WERE INDUSTRY EXPERTS THEY
HAD A PILOT TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND YOU ACTUALLY HAD THE THE
HIGH SCHOOL FOLKS TALKING
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ABOUT.
WHAT COURSES COULD THEY OFFER TO
THE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS THAT
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN PURSUING
THIS CAREER? AND A WHINING THESE
PROGRAMS THERE WAS AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF COORDINATION AND
ENTHUSIASM FOR THIS PROGRAM SO I
THINK THE THE REGIONAL CONSORTIA
HAVE ALREADY SHOWN PROVEN
SUCCESSES THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
OUTCOME DATA. THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN COLLECTED THAT'S AVAILABLE
IN THE LUNCH BOARD WE HAVEN'T
REALLY SEEN OUTCOME DATA FROM
THE INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM SO I
THINK WE'VE KIND OF GOT PROVEN
RESULTS THAT THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING. WE'VE ALSO
YOU KNOW WE'VE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED A LOT OF KEY THROUGH
TWELVE. AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ALIGNMENT THROUGH THE STRONG
WORKFORCE CONSORTIA AND WE JUST
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO EXPAND
UPON IT WE'RE NOT PUTTING THE
DOLLARS. INTO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE DECISIONS ABOUT WHO
WOULD RECEIVE THE CAPE FOR
TWELVE MONEY WOULD BE SWAYED BY
A SEPARATE COMMITTEE. IN THE
CONSORTIUM THAT'S MADE UP OF K.
THROUGH TWELVE.
EXPERTS IN AND PROVIDERS THAT
WOULD BE SELECTED BY CAPABLE OF
STAKEHOLDERS I'M.
I AGAIN I I DON'T KNOW WHY IT
WOULD BE TAKEN OF THAT PART OF
EDUCATION'S HANDS I'VE HEARD
THIS CONCERNS WITH THE WAY
THEY'VE HANDLED THE PAST BUT NO
ONE HAS BROUGHT THOSE CONCERNS
TO THIS COMMITTEE IN THE PAST.
SO THEY HAVE CONCERNS THAT SHE
SAID NOW HE REALLY LAID OUT SO
WE KNOW WHAT THE CHALLENGES ARE.
CD NEEDS MORE SUPPORT DOLLAR
WISE OR WHATEVER TO HELP THESE
TO HANDLE THESE FUNCTIONS SO
MUCH IT SAY THEY SHOULD SAY IN
PUBLIC.
SHOULDN'T BE JUST YOU KNOW KIND
OF YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW THE OPEN SECRET IF YOU
WILL AND ON THAT POINT I WOULD
JUST SAY BECAUSE WE HAVE HEARD
THAT CONCERN AS WELL BUT
PROPOSAL IS NOT STRUCTURED THIS
WAY. AS A SLIGHT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OR OUT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THEY'VE ADMINISTERED
THE CTD PROGRAM IT'S REALLY
STRUCTURED THIS WAY BECAUSE THE
GOAL IS TO GET THESE DOLLARS.
DOWN TO THE LOCAL REGIONAL
CONSORTIA IT'S WHERE LOCAL
DECISION MAKING CAN INFORM BUT
CTE CLASSES THAT ARE BEING
OFFERED IN THE REGION WE THINK
IT'S. IT'S BETTER STRUCTURED
THROUGH OUR PROPOSAL RATHER THAN
HAVING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AT THE STATE LEVEL
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE. YOU KNOW REGIONALLY
LINE.
OKAY I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW HOW THAT WORKS BETTER I'D
STILL HASN'T MEDICS ARTICULATED
A MAN Y. THAT'S A BETTER IDEA.
AND WHY THAT'S NOT EVEN A
PRECEDENT SETTING IDEA WHAT ELSE
ARE WE GONNA HAND OVER TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM TO RUN
WE HAVE OUR OWN.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN THE
AND THEY'RE NOT DOING RIGHT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE NOT
DOING RIGHT SO I CAN HELP FIX
IT.
I MIGHT LIKE TO KEEP YOU KNOW
WHAT WE DO IN HOUSE.
I JUST LIKE KEEP IT THERE PAGES
JUST SEEMS TO BE MORE REFINED.
AND THE MORE PURPOSEFUL.
WITH THAT.
ALTERNATE YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
MY QUESTION FROM THE.
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE. WE.
FUNDAMENTALLY I HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH REGIONAL ALIGNMENT.
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK IN
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY READ WERE
HAVING THEIR ON EMPLOYMENT
RATES.
PROPORTIONAL PROJECTION OF JOB
OPENINGS.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT CHICHI
IN A IN A GROUP AND THE
MORE COMMON SEEN WAY?
IN THE SENSE THAT.
YOUNG WE'RE EXPOSING YOUNG
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY KIDS OF COLOR
AND WOMEN.
TO MATHEMATICS AND SCIENCE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS EARLIER ON
INDICATE TWELVE EDUCATION.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY MAY
NOT DECIDE TO GO INTO THE PRESS
PROGRAM WHICH TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. THAT WE PUT FIFTY FIVE
MILLION. MAY MEAN THAT THEY
DECIDE THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO
CAL TECH CAN BE AN ENGINEER
SOMETHIN SO.
DID THE CT EXPOSURE. IS MUCH
MORE. IN EDUCATION.
THEN A NONVIOLENT RATIO THE.
.
WE. ANOTHER REASON I LIKE IT IS
IN THERE. AND THE.
DECEMBER JANET IS BECAUSE.
WE'VE. OUTLINED IN LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING. WITH A LOCAL CONTROL
PLAN.
AND NOW WE HAVE A DASHBOARD TO
SEE HOW WELL WE'RE DOING.
AND WE'VE SAID A NUMBER YEARS UP
HERE THAT WE WANT TO DASHBOARD.
TO INCLUDE CORRECT ACKNOWLEDGE
CATION AS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
MEASURE.
WELL.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HOLD.
THE SCHOOLS KATIE TWELVE SYSTEM
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
DEVELOPING THEIR EL CAP AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE DASHBOARD.
WHY WOULD THEY DO NOT CONTROL
THE MONEY?
SO TO ME IT JUST MAKES SENSE
THAT'S THERE.
.
AND PROBABLY THE CENTRAL ISSUE
IS NOT THE CENTRAL ISSUE BUT AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
IS THAT
.
THE ORIGINAL PLAN THAT I LOOKED
AT IT JUST DOING THE NUMBER
FIGURES.
ON A ONE TO ONE RATIO WITH
OPPOSE GOVERNOR'S MANAGER OVER
THREE YEARS.
AB ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IT WOULD BE PUTTING IN CT.
WAS A ONE TO ONE MATCH.
IF THEY GO TO TO TO ONE MATCH
YOU KNOW IT'S POINT NINE BILL
IT'S ONLYNINE HUNDRED MILLION
OVER THREE YEARS.
AND ANOTHER COMMITTEE A
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAD HERE WE
TALKED ABOUT UC'S.
OVER IMPACT UC'S AT ONLY FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF EACH GRADUATING CLASS
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO UC AND
WAS OUT THE RIGHT NUMBER.
IN THE CSU.
NUMBER.
WE LAID OUT AT THE ACTUAL.
BUDGETING WE'RE DOING IS THIRTY
THREE PERCENT.
BUT REALITY FORTY ONE PERCENT OF
THE KIDS ARE GOING TO SEE
ISSUES.
AND THAT'S RIGHT NOT THE COSTS
AND THE IMPACT ON THE C. ISSUES.
SO WE'RE DOING A LOT OF MONEY
AND THINGS FOR THAT UPPER FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE KIDS COMING OUT
OF SCHOOL BUT THOSE OTHER
CHILDREN ARE COMING OUT.
WE'RE NOT DOING SO MUCH FOR.
AND I'M WONDERING BUT WE GOING
TO DO FOR THEM.
AND WHEN I'M THINKING ABOUT WHEN
YOU'RE SAYING WELL.
AND I CAME FROM TOWARDS HIGH
SCHOOL.
DE IDEA TO SORT OF GO FROM
TORN'S TO WEST AYE AWARE OF THE
GOING TO BE DOING TO DO THESE
THIS BAG TO DD. CD .
AND MAY WORK FOR CHILDREN WHO
HAVE ABOUT GREATER MEANS TO
TRAVEL.
BUT FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE LOWER
THE ECONOMICS THEY WON'T BE ABLE
TO. THEIR PARENTS ARE GOING TO
PICK A MOP OF MOVING THERE FOR
AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM WAS
THERE NOT TO BE ABLE TO GET A
CAR OVER THERE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE ECONOMIC MEANS TO GET
THERE.
SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
AND I'M
AGREEMENT ALLEN THIS.
WANT TO GET YOUR THAT WE THAT WE
ACTUALLY KEEP THE MONEY IN THE
SCHOOLS FOR THE WORK THEY'RE
DOING.
SO TO ME THE.
THE MONEY WE'RE PUTTING IN OVER
THREE YEARS YOUR PARITY TIME.
OUR PRESENTATION HAD TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE.
THE.
I MUST I SIGNED ON TO A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION OR THREE BILLION
OVER THREE.
DOES I THINK WE'RE IN A
TRANSITION SO YOU CARE BACK THE
GOVERNOR UNDERSTAND WAS TALKING
ABOUT GOING TO SAVE MONEY
EVERYTHING OUT HAD DINNER WITH
HIM LAST NIGHT HE SAID GREAT
THINGS ARE FALLING DOWN NEXT
YEAR. I GOT IT.
BUT TODAY.
WE HAVE THE MONEY.
WE'RE IN A TRANSITION.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TRANSITIONS SINCE HE'D BEEN THE
GOVERNOR WHICH I SUPPORT MANY
THINGS HE'S DONE. I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO. DOUBLE DOWN ON CD .
AND SENATE CLEAR MESSAGE
EVERYBODY AT LEAST FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS.
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST NOT.
FOR THE TOP FIFTY PERCENT THE
KIDS BUT THE OTHER KIDS. THAT
MAY NOT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
SO FOUR MAYBE THEM SEE THE
LIGHT.
AND WE WILL ACTUALLY START HAVE
MORE WOMEN AND MORE PEOPLE COLOR
BECOME ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS.
SO.
YOU'RE HEARING IT FROM THAT ONE
SIDE OF THE AISLE YOU HEAR FROM
THE OTHER SIDE THE AISLE. AND I
THINK I CAN PRETTY MUCH
GUARANTEE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE VOTES
IMPORT CD  AT A HIGHER
LEVEL.
SO PLEASE TAKE THAT MESSAGE
BACK.
YEAH THE SPECIALNESS.
OKAY.
NOW WERE GOING GO ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE.
EDUCATION MANDATES
I BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FRANCE
FINANCES GOING FIRST.
AARON
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AIRING IT OUT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PROPOSAL INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING TO KATO
DAILY ELEAZAR. WHICH ALSO
OFFSETS THE EXISTING MANDATE
CLAIMS THAT FOR THOSE WHO
HAVEN'T.
WITH THIS PROPOSED FUNDING
THE TOTAL OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS UP THROUGH THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
YEAR ALLOCATED FOR THIS PURPOSE
IS APPROXIMATELY SEVEN AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS AND IT WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED ON A PER. EIGHTY
A BASIS ESTIMATED TO EQUAL TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE DOLLARS PER
EIGHTY A PER HELL YEAH.
ADDITIONALLY THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSAL CONTAINS WITHIN IT A
PROPOSAL TO RECOUP ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. OF OVERPAYMENTS
RECEIVED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BY ELEAZAR UNDER THE
SCHOOL BASED MEDI CAL
ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES PROGRAM OR ASTHMA.
THE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED WILL BE
ALLOCATED THIS YEAR AS USUAL
WITH THOSE ELEAZAR.
ó UNDER THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HAVING THEIR ALLOCATION GO
TOWARDS OFFSETTING THAT TOTAL
AMOUNT.
OUT WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS BUT HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MASS MISTER
KAPLAN FROM THE LA JOH.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D DAN CAP WHEN WITH
THE LA SO YOU SHOULD ALL HAVE
RECEIVED A HANDOUT FROM THE
SERGEANT ENTITLED EDUCATION%
MANDATES NOT BE SPEAKING TO THAT
THEY'RE MY PRESENTATION.
THE FIRST PAGES OF A HAND OUT
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF EDUCATION
MANDATES IN WHAT THEY ARE IS
THAT PROPOSITION FOR OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE REQUIRES THE STATE
TO REIMBURSE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES ARE ELEAZAR. FOR THE
ACTIVITIES OF REQUIRES OF THEM.
CURRENTLY THEY'RE FIFTY NINE
SUCH EDUCATION MANDATES ARE
RECOGNIZED BY THE STATE.
AND.
TRADITIONALLY ELEAZAR WENT
THROUGH A PROCESS OF.
PERFORMING THE ACTIVITIES
DOCUMENTING COSTS AND SUBMITTING
CLAIMS TO THE STATE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT.
I'M AS OF TWENTY TWELVE THEIR
OWN ALTERNATIVE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR.
PROCESS WAS DEVELOPED WHEREBY
AND THE STATE DEVELOPED OF
MANDATES BLOCK GRANT AND IN LIEU
OF SUBMITTING CLAIMS.
ELEAZAR COOPER TO
THE PAID IN THE BLOCK GRANT.
AND NOW THE STATE DEFERRED
PAYMENTS TO THIS MANDATE.
TO THESE MANDATES
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS BASICALLY FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE TO TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN AND THAT SUCH.
A LARGE BACKLOG OF MANDATES
CLAIMS DEVELOPED AT THE STATE.
I'M HOWEVER IN RECENT YEARS AS
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER THE STATE
IS COMMITTED PASSED SEVERAL
BILLION DOLLARS TO PAINT DOWN
THIS MANDATE BACKLOG. THOUGH THE
BACKLOG STILL REMAINS AT ALMOST
ONE BILLION.
I THE BREAKDOWN OF THIS IS ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION IS
ASSOCIATED WITH K. TWELVE AND
THE OTHER I HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
NOW WHEN WE LOOK AT THE VERY.
THAT CLAIMS
ON A PER STUDENT BASIS WHICH IS
HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE TWO. OF YOUR
HAND OUT YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE'S
A LARGE VARIATION IN CLAIMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FIRST OF ALL MANY ELEAZAR A
LACK CLAIMS ALTOGETHER ROUGHLY
TWO THIRDS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ONE THIRD OF COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND NEARLY NINETY
PERCENT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE NO OUTSTANDING MANDATE BACK
LOCKS.
FURTHERMORE WHEN WE LOOK ON A
PER STUDENT BASIS WE SEE THAT
THE CLAIMS VARY QUITE
DRAMATICALLY.
FROM KATE ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE.
WITH DISTRICTS THESE CLAIMS CAN
VARY FROM TWO DOLLARS TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
AND IT'S EVEN MORE DRAMATIC WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHERE WE
SEE.
THE CLAIMS VERY ON A PERSONAL
BASIS FROM FORTY FOUR DOLLARS TO
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER STUDENT.
AND THIS IS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT ALL REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
STATE.
REQUIRES THESE ACTIVITIES OF
ALL ELEAZAR.
.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTIONED
THAT THERE I THINK PROVIDED A
GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE RECENT MEDI
CAL BILLING AGREEMENT WHICH IS
HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE THREE OF THE
HANDOUTS ALL SKIP THAT.
AND INSISTS
INSTEAD JUMP TO OUR ASSESSMENT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THREE
MANDATES PROPOSALS.
I AM WHEN IT COMES TO THE MANY
BACKLOG PAYMENTS WE FIND THAT
THE APPROACH IS HIGHLY
INEFFECTIVE AND ELIMINATING THE
BACKLOG OF THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING THAT
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES WE
ESTIMATE THAT IT ONLY REDUCE THE
MANDATES BACKLOG BY ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN.
MILLION DOLLARS.
FURTHERMORE IF THE STATE WERE TO
CONTINUE THIS APPROACH IT WOULD
COST TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
TO FULLY RETIRE. V. I'M ROUGHLY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLAR K. TWELVE
MANDATES BACKLOG.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE MEDI CAL
BILLING REPAIR REPAYMENT
PROPOSAL WE FIND THAT IT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE RECENT OUR
STATE WIDE AGREEMENT THAT WAS
REACHED WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WE FIND THAT
THE.
MANDATES BLOCK GRANT CALL A
PROPOSAL THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
HELPS TO MAINTAIN THE PURCHASING
POWER THE MANDATES BLOCK GRANT.
AS SUCH WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
STATE DEVELOP A MORE STRATEGIC
PLAN TO RETIRING BECKY TWELVE
MANDATES BACKLOG.
SUCH A PLAN COULD HAVE THE STATE
IDENTIFYING AMOUNT THAT'S EQUAL
TO EARN ACCESS OF THE CURRENT
BACKLOG. ON TO DISTRIBUTE
FUNDING ON A PER STUDENT BASIS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING FUNDING REQUIRE
ELEAZAR FULLY RETIRED THEIR
MANDATE BACKLOG CLEAN SURFACE.
LEVEL.
AND FINALLY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT THE
GOVERNOR'S MEDI CAL REPAYMENT
AND CALL UP PROPOSALS BANKIA.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
SEPARATE UP HAVE A STATEMENT AND
IN THE PUBLIC INSTRUCTION AT TOM
PRO EXTENT AT THE DEPARTMENT'S
ROLE IN THE MANDATE PROCESSES IS
VERY LIMITED SO I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD BUT AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE OKAY. THANK YOU.
FOR THIS IS NOT A.
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC BUT IT'S
LARGELY A KIND OF A BALANCER AT
THE END OF THE. BUDGET PROCESS
DEPENDING ON.
HOW MUCH?
WE HAVE AN AND I I THINK YOU
OUTLINED THE ISSUE.
AND ALEJO'S PERSPECTIVE.
WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT OUT AND JUST
GIVE IT ON A PROPORTIONAL BASIS
THE LAST FEW YEARS KNOWING THAT
IT'S THERE UNEQUAL. ON.
.
LIST AS FAR AS VIA BACKLOG
REQUESTS BUT IN IT IT BUT
KNOWING THAT WE'RE NOT REDUCING
THE OVERALL.
DEAL WITH.
CHAVEZ.
SO YOU KNOW QUESTIONS ON THIS
BILL WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
LAST ISSUE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATE OPERATION.
BUDGET PROPOSALS
.
THANK YOU ACUTENESS I'M WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOING TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S.
STATE OPERATIONS BUDGET AS
PROPOSED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND I MOVE ON TO THE
SPECIFIC ADJUSTMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE AGENDA. US SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A TOTAL OF THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STATE OPERATIONS.
AT THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION OF
THIS AMOUNT TO OUR SIXTY FIVE
MILLION IS PROVIDED TO SUPPORT
PROXIMALLY FIFTEEN HUNDRED
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT HEADQUARTERS IN THAT
CONSISTS OF FIFTY FIVE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO MILLION AND FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND TWENTY EIGHT MILLION AND
OTHER FUNDS THE REMAINING ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
US SUPPORTS APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS AT THE STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS. AND DIAGNOSTIC CENTERS
ON THIS CONSISTS OF FIFTY ONE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. AND ELEVEN
MILLION AND OTHER FUNDS.
SO MOVING ON TO THE US SPECIFIC
ADJUSTMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA THERE'S NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND. OF FOR
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION TO CONTINUE
DEVELOPING REVISING CONTENT
STANDARDS IN SPECIFIED SUBJECT
AREAS AS OUTLINED IN VARIOUS
PIECES OF LET RECENT
LEGISLATION.
THERE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND
REAPPROPRIATION GEORGETTE
ADDRESS ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD AT
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
INFORMATION SERVICES.
PROGRAM.
THERE'S TWO OUT IN NINETY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OVERSEE
ADDITIONAL STATE PRESCHOOL UP
PROGRAM CONTRACTS.
THERE'S ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT DRESSED
ADDITIONAL DATA SECURITY AND
PRIVACY WORKLOAD.
AS ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT REVIEW AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WITH REGARD TO DISTRICT
REORGANIZATIONS.
THERE IS ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO COMPLETE ADDITIONAL
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. REVIEWS OF
BASED ON RECENT LEGISLATION.
AND THERE IS A HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO ASSIST
SCHOOLS IN APPLYING FOR THE
UNIVERSAL MEAL SERVICE PROGRAM.
ON PURSUANT TO RECENT
LEGISLATION AS WELL.
.
AND THEN THERE'S ANOTHER ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL TELL
TO FUNDS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ARM IN
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
LASTLY SIX AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING.
CREATE A LITIGATION UNITS
RESPOND PUBLIC INFORMATION
REQUESTS AND OTHER WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION LITIGATION.
THAT CONCLUDES MY SUMMARY IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE LET
ME.
OKAY.
BRIAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE EARLY THE
SEWERS THE DEPARTMENT LAID OUT
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROPOSALS.
RELATED TO ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN THE
BUDGET.
EACH OF THESE REFERENCES EITHER
A LONG STANDING.
CONCERNED ABOUT CAPACITY WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OR OR A SPECIFIC.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WHICH
INCREASE THE WORKLOAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND IN ALL CASES
EXCEPT FROM ONE WE WE THOUGHT
THAT.
AND IT IN FACT THE.
.
AUGMENTATION WAS JUSTIFIED BY
THE.
.
A. CITATION. I'D IN THE ONE AREA
WHERE WE HAVE CONCERN A IT
RELATES TO A. RECENT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AB SIX NINE NINE
THAT WE JUST DON'T BELIEVE.
IT NOTABLY INCREASES THE
WORKLOAD FOR THE DEPARTMENT SO
LITTLE BACKGROUND HERE. I'D
CURRENT CURRENT LAW SO BEFORE AB
SIX NINE NINE IS SCHOOLS WERE
REQUIRED.
INTO.
ENSURE THAT THEY HAD
APPROPRIATE POLICIES ENSURING
NON DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
STUDENTS FOR VARIETY OF
CHARACTERISTICS.
DISABILITY GENDER GENDER
IDENTITY GENDER EXPRESSION
NATIONALITY RACE RELIGION
ETHNICITY RELIGION SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
BUT TO THIS LIST AB SIX NINE
NINE ADDED IMMIGRATION STATUS
NOW IN ORDER TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CURRENT.
WITH EXISTING LAW SCHOOLS WERE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO HAVE
POLICIES SPECIFYING HOW THEY
WOULD ENSURE NON DISCRIMINATION
AND HOW THEY WOULD INVESTIGATIVE
FOLLOW UP ON REPORTS OF
DISCRIMINATION OR BOWLING BASED
ON THESE CHARACTERISTICS.
AND IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
DISTRICTS WERE FOLLOWING THAT
REQUIREMENT THE DEPARTMENT.
DID ANNUAL THE.
NUMBER OF AUDITS OF SCHOOLS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAD
APPROPRIATE POLICIES INCREASE.
PLACE A SPECIFIC WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
AUDITED FORTY A DISTRICTS EVERY
YEAR THEY HAD TO STAFF MEMBERS
TO DO THAT. OUT.
UP THE ASK FROM THE DEPARTMENT
WAS FOR.
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO.
COMPLETE THOSE AUDITS NOW THAT.
IMMIGRATION STATUS WAS ADDED.
THE SPECIFIC FUNDS THAT WERE.
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET WOULD
INCREASE THAT CAPACITY BY ABOUT
FIFTY PERCENT IN ADDITIONAL
STAFF AND WHICH IS NOT CLEAR ON
A WIDE THE MARGINAL INCREASE OF
INCLUDING IMMIGRATION STATUS ON
THIS ALREADY LONG LIST OF.
OF.
PROTECTED CATEGORIES WOULD
JUSTIFY SECTION BARGE INCREASE.
ASIDE FROM THAT AS I SAID WE HAD
NO CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS.
OKAY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF A STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TAR LOOKS AND
I'M BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT
WHERE WE SUPPORT THE A PROPOSAL
PUT FORTH BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
IN A PARTICULAR ONE AND NOTE ON
THAT THAT THAT WE'RE PLEASED TO
SEE THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
BEING INCLUDED IN THAT. JANUARY
BUDGET HELPS MAINTAIN AND THAT
THE CONTINUITY OF THAT WORKS
AWARE APPRECIATIVE OF THAT AND
ALSO THE FUNDING FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION WORK LITIGATION UNIT
WE THINK THAT'S AN. AREA OF NEED
TO WEAR WERE ALSO PARTICULARLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK TO THE M.. THAT THE
CONCERNS AROUND THE ADDITIONAL
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH WITH
AB SIX NINETY NINE OBVIOUSLY WE
SUPPORT THE. US DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROPOSAL TO TO FIND THAT
THOSE POSITIONS WILL ACTUALLY DO
THINK THAT THAT LEGISLATION
REQUIRED MORE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
BECAUSE THIS IS A PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX AND HIGHLY CHARGED ISSUE
AND SO WE THINK THAT THE AND THE
THAT THAT IT REQUIRES MORE ON
THE DEPARTMENT TO BETTER HELP US
SUPPORT DISTRICTS AS THERE IS
THERE. AT BEING CHALLENGED BY
THIS AREA AND SO WE ARE WE WHO
HAVE REQUESTED POSITIONS TO HELP
DEVELOP POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
TO. TO ENSURE THAT ELEAZAR
COMPLYING WITH THE.
ISSUES AROUND THEM RATIONS THAT
IS THAT WE'RE MONITORING IT
THOSE AGENCIES AND ALSO THAT
WERE EXAMINING THE ADDITIONAL.
AT DOCUMENTATION. THAT DID THAT
ELEAZAR NEED TO SHOW THAT THEY
ARE COMPLYING WITH THAT HE ALSO
ANOTHER AREA JUST AS THEY NOTED
THAT THIS IS PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT DISTRICTS HAVE THE RIGHT.
LEVEL OF SUPPORT SO IT'S ALSO
AROUND PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND AGAIN THIS WAS
NOT I DON'T BELIEVE THE INTENT
WAS JUST AROUND PREFER SENDING
GUIDANCE LETTERS TO DISTRICTS
THAT THAT THAT THAT WASN'T
ENOUGH AND THAT IT DOES REQUIRE
MORE. AND SO WE AS SUPPORT THE
AD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES I'M
FUNDING PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND AND HOPE
TO HAVE THAT LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
ON THAT AS WELL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU LET ME JUST ASK THE
PART OF EDUCATION AREARE THERE
OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU.
YOU WISH IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THAT JANUARY TEN.
BUDGET AS FAR AS.
NEEDS AND STATE OPERATIONS OF
CD.
THAT IT WE WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
OTHER REQUESTS OUT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT THAT
WHEN THAT WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
THEY HAVE DEFERRED UNTIL MAY AND
SO. WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM ON
GETTING SOME MORE INFORMATION
AND HELP THAT DOES SO IT IT
INCLUDES SOME YOU WE HAVE
REQUEST AROUND TO THE.
AT THAT.
ENGLISH ONE A PROFICIENCY
EXAMINATION.
AMONG OTHERS AND SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK AND AND.
AT NATIONALS THAT I AM I
REQUEST AROUND THE AND THE PILOT
BILLS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED LAST FOR EARLY EDUCATION
AND SO WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ON THAT. OKAY YOU COULD SURPRISE
THIS IS SAID NO.
OKAY.
I CAN'T SEE THAT.
OKAY FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THESE
POSITIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT CD.
I SEEING NONE. WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN AS WELL.
NO ONE CAN MOVE THAT WE ACTUALLY
GONNA FINALLY CLOSE OUT AND
ISSUE HERE. ARE MOVERS ITEM HERE
ISSUE SIX.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND.
SECOND I MISS THE AMOUNT TO GIVE
TO APPROVE THESE POSITIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY BY CABINET AYE. AMONG.
MEDINA.
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
I.
VOEPEL.
OKAY WILL NOW START WITH OUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS CAN YOU PLEASE
LINE UP IN THE MIDDLE ON AND
IT'S ALWAYS PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO. ONE MINUTE OR LESS.
OKAY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTY BAO
MOMMY OF CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR ABOUT. OUR
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
APPRENTICESHIP ITEM OF WE WILL
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
FINANCE THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
BUT ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. A DEALING
WITH USING F. T. E. IS A FUNDING
SOURCE FOR PARTNERSHIP.
OPPRESSION IS FUNDED ON A
REIMBURSEMENT BASIS ON PER HOUR
OF TRAINING TO ENSURE THAT MOST
THE HIGHEST LOW ACCOUNTABILITY
FD AS YOU KNOW THE CENSUS BASED
APPROACH. US SO WE THINK THAT
THAT PRINT PRESENTS PROBLEMS IN
THE REIMBURSEMENT. A LIKEWISE
USING FTP MEANS YOU HAVE TO USE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS
WHICH.
FOR PRECIOUS MEANS ALL OF THE
JOURNEY MEN AND WOMEN WHO
PROVIDE THE TRAINING NOW WOULD.
BE PROHIBITED FROM PROVIDING THE
TRAINING.
BUT WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS.
HELEN ROTH TELL THEM SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND WERE ACTUALLY
RECIPIENT OF THE CAI GRANTS THAT
ARE NOTED. IN THE HIGHWAY WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IN REJECT WITH THE LA O. HAS
SAID ABOUT THE I'M NOT PAYING
THE HIGHER RATES FOR IN THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST FOR THE
INSTRUCTORS. WE ARE DOING
PROGRAMS LV INTO OUR AND
FINANCIAL SERVICES WHICH IS
AUDITOR ACCOUNTING.
CYBERSECURITY AND IT ALL OF
THOSE REQUIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THEY'RE DIFFERENT THAN THE IT.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ONCE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT THAN FIREFIGHTERS AND.
AND AS WE MOVE END TO THESE AND
THESE ARE GREAT.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THERE'S
NO SUSTAINABILITY WHEN YOU SAY
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU
ARE GOING TO LOWER THE AMOUNT
THAT THEY GET BACK SO WE ARE
OPPOSING THE US. AS WE MOVE IN
IN THE WITH THESE INNOVATION
GRANTS AND CALIFORNIA'S THE
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY TO BE DOING
MASS ON WITH FINANCIAL SERVICES
WERE DOING A AT AMERICAN RIVER.
SO PEOPLE CAN TAKE THEIR CPA'S
THE LVM WHO STARTS NOW AT FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND IS MOVING TO
NINETY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR THROUGH A PROGRAM AT DELTA.
WE'RE DOING ANOTHER ONE AT SAKS
CITY SO THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS BUT THEY ARE BASED IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE
MOVE INTO THESE WHITE COLLAR
PROFESSIONS. THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TO DO AND THAT'S WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICES RECOGNIZING
IN THEIR PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
JERRY MCCARTY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
VIETNAM GONZALEZ AND PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE FARM WORKER
INSTITUTE OF EDUCATION. AND
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT ALSO
KNOWN AS FIELD OR FIELD
INSTITUTE.
FIELD WAS DUMBFOUNDED BY.
CAESAR TRAVIS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT TO MEET THE
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS.
A FARMWORKERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
IN ADDITION TO LEARNING ENGLISH
AND PROVIDING CITIZENSHIP
CLASSES.
ADULT FARM WORKER IN LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING.
IT'S HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS.
OUR PROGRAMS MEET OR EXCEED ALL
STATE STANDARDS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE ONE TIME THREE YEAR BUDGET
AUGMENTATION.
FOR ARE SPONSORING COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION.
WHICH ALLOWS US TO DOUBLE OUR
ROMAN FROM SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
A FIFTEEN THOUSAND ANNUALLY.
BUT A TIME WHEN A GROWING NUMBER
OF FARMWORKERS ONE A PURSUE
CITIZENSHIP. HELPING THEM
PREPARE IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF YOU.
NICHOLAS HOW THIS ON BEHALF
UNITED FARM WORKERS
AND SUPPORT OF THE FORMER
INSTITUTE EDUCATION LEADERSHIP
AND DEVELOPMENT. ONE TIME THREE
YEAR AUGMENTATION REQUEST.
WHICH SUPPORTS FARMWORKERS
EDUCATION IN THEIR PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
MAKE IT.
OF MATTHEW COKE AND.
ORDER DIRECTOR FOR ADULT
EDUCATION FOR UNITED TEACHERS
LOS ANGELES I'M ALSO VICE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS. AND.
TEACH ESL ONE BE.
TWO ADULTS IT OUT AND HIS
COMMITTEE ADULT SCHOOL I WANT
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE.
ADULT EDUCATION CREDENTIAL AND
SOME REASONS WHY THIS TO MY NEXT
DAY UNEXPECTED CONSEQUENCES WILL
COME OF THAT.
I THINK MOST ADULT ED TEACHERS.
ARE IN TEACHERS UNIONS WERE
EVERY TEACHER IS CREDENTIALED.
I THINK WE'LL HAVE LONG TERM
AFFECTS WITH THE ONLY TEACHERS
NOT BUT EVEN WORSE.
THE EDUCATION CODE DOESN'T SAY
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHER SAYS
CERTIFICATED PERSONNEL.
I THING MY MY DISTRICT LAUSD
WOULD BE VERY AGGRESSIVE.
TOWARDS TEACHERS IF WE CHANGE
THAT NOT CERTIFICATE HAVING A
BETTER SOLUTION.
WOULD BE SIMPLY TO MAKE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE ADULT ED
CREDENTIAL.
SAME AS THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS.
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THAT WOULD MEAN EVERY ADULT THE
TEACHER COULD TEACHING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TEACHERS.
COULD SIMPLY ASK FOR THEIR
CREDENTIAL BECAUSE THEY'VE
ALREADY.
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
FURTHER I THINK THE ADULT THAT
BLOCK GRANT IS GREAT IT DOESN'T
MY STUDENTS WANT THAT MOVES IN
TOWARDS JOB TRAINING HOWEVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN MY DISTRICT
ABOUT A QUARTER OF ADULT IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS BEEN GLACIALLY
SLOW IN IMPLEMENTATION.
MY STUDENTS.
ARE GETTING NO COUNSELING FOR
JOB TRAINING.
THERE ARE VERY FEW ARE MOVING ON
A AND LIKE REACHED TALK.
YEAH I LIKE IT THOUGH THAT THEY
GIVE YOU DOUBLE.
ALRIGHT WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALSO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE IS A TEACHER.
HOW ARE YOU GAVE YOU THAT OF?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TRISTEN
BROWN MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
TEACHERS.
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF OUR
VICE PRESIDENT BUT ALSO JUST
WANTING TO.
ROUTE ITERATE THE US SUPPORT
FOR KEEPING CD  I AS ITS
IMPLEMENTED CURRENTLY WITH THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
WOULD LIKE TO DIRECTION THAT
THE HOUSE IS MOVING IT CURRENTLY
AND AND HOPE THAT THAT ENDS UP
AS THE OUR FINAL SOLUTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
ON KEPT HIM HALF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULT EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION BOTH
KEY TWELVE I DON'T EDUCATION
ASSOCIATIONS. I WOULD LIKE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
AROUND COLA.
AS WELL AS AT THE DATA FUNDING
AND DIRECTORY TO LANGUAGE I
PLANNING TIMELINE I WOULD ALSO
URGE THE COMMITTEE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER PER
THE CHAIRS QUESTIONING.
INCREASING IN THE ADULT
EDUCATION FUNDING OVERALL FOR
THE BLOCK GRANT COLORS VERY
IMPORTANT VERY SUPPORTIVE IT
WILL ONLY ADDRESS ON JUST THE
COST INCREASES TO DATE NOT HELP
TO EXPAND CAPACITY TO THOSE
NEEDED. A WE WOULD ALSO ADAM AS
WE'VE TALKED WITH THE.
CHAIR STAFF AND REALLY SUPPORT
TO INCLUSION AND IF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION METRICS INTO THE
BLOCK GRANT AS WELL AS CHANGING
THE TERM GRANT CHINA IN ADULT
THAT BLOCK GRANT. OF FINALLY
JUST TWO QUICK POINTS REGARDING
ALEJO RECOMMENDATIONS I
CERTAINLY WITH REGARD TO THE FEE
DISCUSSION WE'RE HAPPY TO ENGAGE
IN A DISCUSSION. OUT WE WOULD
NOTE SHOT THAT THAT WILL REQUIRE
A BACK FILL OF FUNDING OF TO
SUPPORT THE TIME THOSE PROGRAMS
ABSENT THAT ADDITIONAL A CUTS
WILL BE MADE IN THAT AREA.
ADDITIONALLY I WE WOULD ECHO
CONCERNS REGARDING THE
ELIMINATION OUT RIGHT OF THE
CREDENTIAL REQUIREMENTS OUT WE
ARE WORKING ON PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STREAMLINE NOT. UP WE THINK THAT
THAT'S WRONG HEADED JUST
OUTRIGHT ELIMINATED THE GIVE AND
THEN LASTLY ON THEIR ON THE
ELLIOT RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN
ASKED IF. THE ASSOCIATION COULD
WORK WITH OUR OUR STAFF TO TO TO
DIE WITH WITH THE NOT YOU THINK
THESE ARE ARE REALLY FOR THE.
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU SALINAS
CHAIR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SPAM CENTER SERUM
SANTANA REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE ARE A
CIVIL RIGHTS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. THE MAJORITY OF
THE CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE OUR
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT AND
HAVE LOW BASIC SKILLS AND WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION METRICS.
AS OUTLINED IN THE WHITE PAPER
TO BE INCLUDED IN ADULT
EDUCATION AND ALSO WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INCENTIVE
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITIES OF NEED
WHICH INCLUDE THE LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT POPULATIONS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHARGING OF
THE SOLO AT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL'S WITH REGARDS TO DAHLE
EDUCATION FOR INCENTIVE FUNDING
TO REACH POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
MULTIPLE BARRIERS. AND ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WITH REGARDS TO
AT ALL EDUCATION WE ARE LOOKING
AT.
MEASURING IMMIGRANT TO CREATION
AND INCLUSION WHICH REALLY HELPS
PROPEL A CALIFORNIANS IMMIGRANTS
NOT JUST ON THE EMPLOYMENT SIDE
BUT ALSO HELPING THEM A
CONTRIBUTE PARTICIPATE MORE WITH
AND I'M SOCIETY THANK YOU.
MY ANGER I'M A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA CAN BE ANY MEMBER OF
THE SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION
ROUNDTABLE THE ROUNDTABLE
SUBMITTED A LETTER. AYE
REQUESTING SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND STAFF POSITIONS FOR CD TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL OVERSIGHT TO
SEX EDUCATION. IS THIS FUNDING
IS NECESSARY TO PREVENT THE LOSS
OF SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED TODAY WOULD PREVENT THE
LOSS OF CDA GUIDANCE TO LOCAL
SCHOOLS AND OVERSIGHT ON THEIR
CURRICULUMS INCLUDING SELECTIVE
AUDITS. IT PREVENT THE LOSS OF.
STATISTICAL GATHERING ON SEXUAL
HEALTH BEHAVIORS IN YOUTH THIS
INFORMATION IS THEN USE FAR.
LEGISLATURES AND AGENCIES TO
INFORM THE DECISION MAKING ON
BEST PRACTICES GOING FORWARD.
AND IT ALSO WOULD PREVENT THE
LOSS OF CRITICAL COORDINATION
BETWEEN STATE AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON ISSUES OF SEXUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION. AND THIS WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THE SEXUAL
HEALTH LAWS WILL BE PASSED UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACT
ACTUALLY GET IMPLEMENTED IN OUR
SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
ONLY ST LOUIS WITH A CALIFORNIA
LATINAS FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
NEARING ALSO MY COMMENTS.
WITH THE ACLU THE FURTHERING AT
THAT UP UNTIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FOR THE PAST THIRTY YEARS CD
HAS RECEIVED FEDERAL
FUNDING.
FOUR DASH THIS MONIES ALLOWED
CD TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
LEADERSHIP AND HELPING WITH THE
QUALITY SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION
AS WELL AS ADDRESSING EACH. IBM
STI PREVENTION EDUCATIONS ITS
BEEN BROUGHT COORDINATION IN
WORKING WITH.
PROMOTING ADOLESCENT HEALTH AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY LGBT Q.
STUDENTS.
THE RECENT PASSAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACT HAS
MADE CDS LEADERSHIP EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WHAT THE CUTS WITH
DASH AND RECENTLY ANNOUNCEMENTS
THAT THEY WILL NO LONGER FUNDS
CDS. OR ANY OTHER STATE AGENCY
IS IT'S AN ELIMINATES YOU
POSITIONS THAT ARE GONNA BE
VITAL FOR NOT ONLY ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE.
BROAD SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION
BUT ALSO THAT WE'RE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW SO JUST
IN TERMS OF GETTING A FUNDING
BACK IN THERE AND ENSURING THAT
WE ARE PROTECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. FROM ENDING
UP IN ON DIRE SITUATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I AM
ANDREAS AND MIGUEL ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO.
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE SECOND
ROUND TABLE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
CD . AND. IN THE PAST
DECADE UNINTENDED PREGNANCY.
HAS DROPPED TO A LOW BUT RECORD
LOW AND THE TWO YEARS FOLLOWING
THE ENACTMENT OF CHAI AT THE
PERCENTAGE OF SEXUALLY ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WHO USE
BIRTH CONTROL HAS INCREASED?
THIS PROGRESSES ALL ATTRIBUTES
TO CALIFORNIA'S DEDICATION TO
COMPREHENSIVE SEX ED.
AND AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED HOWEVER
THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO IF WE
PLAN TO ADDRESS THE GAPS IN
UNINTENDED PREGNANCY RATES
REFLECTED BY THE STATE'S.
PERSISTENT GEOGRAPHIC AND
RACIAL DISPARITIES.
WE ALSO MUST WORK AS THE STATE'S
HALT THE RISING STI RATES
AMATEUR PARTICULARLY.
HIGH.
AMONG USE AGE FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR. SO PLAN PARENTS
STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
THIS CRITICAL.
BUT MEASURED FUNDING REQUEST
AND.
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST IF ANYONE
WITH THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION IN SUPPORT
OF THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CNA ON STAFFING INCREASE FOR
TRAINING.
WE APPRECIATE THE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS HOWEVER RELIGIOUS NOTE
THAT IT'S ONE TIME FUNDING AND
WE WOULD.
PASS US CONSIDER ONGOING
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
I'M ACTUALLY MEET THAT THE
REQUIREMENT OF INCREASE STAFFING
WE APPRECIATE THE LA O. IN THEIR
PROPOSALS PUT FORTH TODAY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR ANALYSIS
ON ALL. OF THE FUNDING
ASSOCIATED TENDENCY IN EIGHT YOU
THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MATT ROBINSON THE
CALVARY SUFFICIENT HEALTH
FACILITIES REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA ICE TO
WEAR IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHT SEVEN ZERO WITH
A CNA TRAINING PROGRAMS
INCOMMUNICADO EDGES. I THINK
ANALYSIS IN A VERY GOOD JOB OF
US AND WHAT IS THE ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH OUR WORK FOR
SHORTAGE.
WE ARE ALSO SPONSOR BILL AB TWO
EIGHT FIVE ZERO THAT.
EXPLORES OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL TO CUT STREAMLINED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TRAINING
WHICH IS AB TWO EIGHT FIVE ZERO
THAT'S THIS AFTERNOON AND HEALTH
BUT I WOULD LOOK FOR TO DISCUSS
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT WE'RE
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
WE'D LIKE TO FIRST THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR.
PRETTY PARTNERSHIP ISSUE IT.
PRIMARILY ON THE U. LOOK BACK
FUNDING GOING BACK TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND THE
AUGMENTED ONGOING FUNDING FOR
APPRENTICESHIP.
FUNDING A WE HAVE UNIONS THAT
ARE LITERALLY.
.
TWO THOUSAND FOR THOUSANDS OF
HOURS OF TRAINING THEY PROVIDED
ALREADY GOING BACK THREE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN SO THAT LOOK
BACK IS VERY IMPORTANT TO THEM.
WE ALSO ARE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO KEEP THE FUNDING METHOD UNDER
THE RSI MODEL IT'S OF THE F. T.
MODEL LIKE A Y. MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS REALLY AREN'T
FINALLY.
I COULD HAVE HAD A BETTER THAN
THE CHAIR WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AND SENATE GRANT PROPOSAL.
NORTH OF TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS GREAT.
THE CURRENT.
IT'S AN IMMIGRANT MODEL WE
BELIEVE WORKS BEST HOUSE THAT CD
. AN INTERESTING PARTNER
BUT THAT.
.
CD  SINCE THEY COVER THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM THEY NEED TO BE
THE ONES THAT HOUSE THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE OF HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION
MIDDLE SCHOOL EDUCATION IS ABOUT
HOLISTIC. LOOK AT YOUR FUTURE
WHAT YOU CAN DO OF THE STRONG
FORCE PROGRAMS ABOUT PROVIDING.
WORKERS TO THE WORK FORCE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
ROBUST CT PROGRAM THAT I SCHOOLS
MIDDLE SCHOOLS OF KIDS HAVE AN
IDEA WHAT'S.
WAITING FOR THEM AFTER I SCHOOL
WHETHER IT'S COLLEGE OR CAREER
THANK YOU.
AND TO GET RIGHT TO IT THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I WOULD REFERENCE AYE ISSUE
THREE ADULT EDUCATION. I WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR A COLA AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO LIE MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE. COCAINE IN REFERENCE
TO THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
FOR TEACHING IN CAPE TO TWELVE
WE LOOK BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE ALIGNING WITH THOSE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE THE
LAUSD WOULD SUPPORT THAT AND WE
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
GO ABOUT DOING THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
JERRY SHELTON ON BEHALF OF K.
ROB THE ASSOCIATION OF CAREER IN
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED FOR.
STABLE ONGOING FUNDING FOR CD
BUT WE CLEARLY SUPPORT THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS AND MANY OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS COMMENTS.
WITH RESPECT TO BOTH THE
FUNDING LEVEL AND THE
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE FOR.
ADMINISTERING THAT FUNDING
SHOULD ALSO A NOTE THAT WE
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION INCLUDING
SIX OF THE SEVEN COUNTY OFFICES
THAT CURRENTLY SERVE AS.
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS UNDER THE CT INCENTIVE
GRANT. SO WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSIST.
THANK YOU.
HOUSE OF AN ENEMY IS NOT TO NOT
HAVE CHILDREN NOW HERE ON BEHALF
OF AN ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
WHERE URGING THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER USING THE ONE TIME
FUNDING. TO INVEST TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
EDUCATORS IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
FRAMEWORK. ON HAND THE ENGLISH
LIT LEARN A ROADMAP WE PROPOSE
THAT ALLOCATION TROUBLING
DOLLARS TO USE THESE ONE TIME
FUNDS. AND TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITIES OF
PRACTICE AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL TO HELP
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF EDUCATORS
ACROSS THE STATE. I AM HERE WITH
OUR PARTNERS CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND CRAPPIE.
GOOD MORNING MARTHA DERECHOS
IDEAS OF REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT. OF THE REQUESTS OF
TWELVE MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL LA
ELT PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
ALONG WITH THAT TRAINING
SPECIFIC TO THE ENGLISH ON A
ROAD MAP.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE FEEL
THAT THERE'S A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ELT. OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THE L. ROADMAP
JUST CAME OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. AND DISTRICTS TO
NAY THIS GUIDANCE WITH REGARDS
TO HOW TO PROVIDE A QUALITY
BETTER EDUCATION FOR OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANNA JOHNSON FROM
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW I'M JUST HERE TO SAY THAT
THE NATIONAL CENTER FEES LAWS
SUPPORTS THE FUNDING FOR THE CD
POSITIONS I WOULD PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND GUIDANCE. TO
SCHOOLS ON THE CRITICAL SEXUAL
EDUCATION CURRICULUM THAT ARE
USE REALLY NEED THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS FLOOR
WHAT'S GOING ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF THE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL AND SENATE
GRANTS WITH REGIONAL TECHNICAL
STRUCTURE.
WE SUPPORT CONTINUING THIS AT
THE CD  LEVEL I'M WE'VE
BELIEVED THAT THE DEPARTMENT
DOES A GOOD JOB ORGANIZING IT
AND ALSO HELPS US REACH.
THE AT RISK YOUTH THAT ACTUALLY.
TANE SERVICES THROUGH THIS
DIVISION SO WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON.
CURRENT TECHNICAL AT IN
ADDRESSING.
THE NEEDS OF THE AT RISK YOUTH
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARC OUT PARTISAN
THEY HAVE OF ACTS OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS OUR IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THEM
FOUR POINT ONE PERCENT COLOR FOR
THAT OLD EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT.
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
CALL LIFE AND ONGOING COLA AND
JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE THERE'S
INCREASED COSTS AFFORD FOR THAT
MAKE COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
ON ANOTHER ISSUE IS THAT ONE
TIME DOLLARS THE PROPOSED ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FOR
DISCRETIONARY. AREN'T ON A PER
STUDENT BASIS WE SUPPORT THE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
CALL TWO THE UNDERSHIRT ACROSS
THE STATE ON A PER EIGHTY EIGHT
BASIS. HOWEVER WE DO OPPOSE THE
GOVERNORSHIP OPPOSE AND
REAPPROPRIATION OF TUNER AND
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS OUT
TO REPAY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ON THE SMALL MEDI CAL SCHOOL
BASED ACTIVITIES. AND WE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH A LETTER ON THAT
PARTICULAR CONCERN. AYE LASTLY
MCT  I WITHOUT GOING ON
DOWN THE SLIPPERY SLOPE ABOUT
TRADING BACK CATEGORICAL SO ON
AS HE WAS MENTIONED TODAY WE DO
BELIEVE THAT CITY E. PROVIDES A
VALUE TO OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
WORKFORCE AND HELPING THE
ECONOMY. I WOULD SUPPORT A
CONTIN INVESTMENT IN CT ARE WE
HAVE NOT AWAITING YET THOUGH IN
WHICH IS THE BEST BUT I'M
STRUCTURE POSSIBLE THINKS.
HELLO MY NAME'S AMELIA AND I'M
STICKING YOUR YOU SEE OUR EMPIRE
OF RICE CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH
I'M NOT PRIVATE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE I BELIEVE STUDENTS
SHOULD I THE KEY FOR EACH OTHER.
IF COLLEGE IF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS CAN MAKE IT TO THIS
HEARING THEM WE SHOP FOR THEM.
OVERAWE A WOMAN PUBLIC COMMENT
TO SERVICE AS A REMINDER THAT
ONE IN FIVE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS INTO
THIRDS FACE WITH INSECURITY.
ON THIS WAS SERVICE EVERY POPE
PUBLISHED LAST JUNE AND I DOUBT.
MUCH IS CHANGE AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD I HOPE YOU KEEP
STATISTICS LIKE THIS IN MIND IT
SEEMS THAT MOST WANT. TO HELP
AND SERVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD
EDUCATION SYSTEM IF THEIR BASIC
NEEDS ARE MET FIRST THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS VINCENT
RASO I'M WITH THESE AND I'M A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY ACT LIKE I
PERSONALLY DON'T EXPERIENCE MY
EDUCATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE SYSTEM BUT BOTH MY
SISTERS ARE ENROLLED IN ON THE
RIVERS TECHNICAL AGE AND SO WITH
THAT EXPERIENCE AND JUST
GENERALLY SPEAKING. HOMAGE FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT MANY
COLLEGES THE AFFORDABILITY OF
THEM ATTRACTS A WIDER RANGE OF
LOWER INCOME STUDENTS AND I'M
WITH THE INLAND EMPIRE AND YOU
SEE ARE SPECIFICALLY THE
FINANCIAL PACKAGE THAT WE
PROVIDED ON IT ATTRACTS A LARGE
INFLUX OF THESE COMEDICALLY
TRANSFERS. ARM SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT ON
THREE COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE THIS
ASPIRATION TO.
TWO FOR A PURSUE THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION HOMAGE TO THE FACT I
OR AM ONE THING THAT I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT THE.
THESE PROGRAMS AS FAR AS
SICKENING COLLEGES GO ON ME TO
BE HELD THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LARGER ON ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF TWO LOCAL
DISTRIBUTION. THAT THESE.
PROGRAMS PROVIDE ESPECIALLY
WHEN I'M
YOU YOU SEE LIKE AND DISPATCH
HAS COMMITTEES THAT BENITO I'M
UPLIFT THEIR MARGINALIZED VOICES
TOM.
BECAUSE. THERE'S NOT THEY DON'T
GET OUT OF IT THEY DON'T GET
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
SIMPLY TO LINE REACHED AS A
PRIMARY SOURCES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING WHEN ANGRY ABOUT
HALF A UC RIVERSIDE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR ALLEGIANCE
ARE AMONG HERE TODAY ON TO SORT
OF REMIND AGAIN THAT WE'RE HERE
I'M I'M SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. UC RIVERSIDE
IS ONE OF THE ONLY YOU WHAT A
LARGE ON. A LARGE CAMPUS WHERE
WE HAVE A LOT OF TRANSFER
STUDENTS FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ON IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMIND YOU THAT COMMITTEE
COLLEGES AGAIN ON THE CHART THE
LARGE RANGE OF LIKE MARGINALIZED
GROUPS MINORITIES. I'M
SPECIFICALLY LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN IDENTIFYING ON
INDIVIDUALS MAKING SURE.
ALL EL AL ASKING A AND I URGE
DON THE COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE ALLOCATING CERTAIN
PROGRAMS AND FUNDS AND TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION MINORITIES
AND OFTEN. DOES WHERE THERE ONCE
OR SILENCE THAT SPECIFICALLY
THESE KIND OF HEARING SO THANK
YOU.
HELEN ROTH DOWDEN TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS I PUT MY COMMENTS
IN THIS PROPOSAL BUT WONDER
BRIEFLY AS I. SAY THIS IS ABOUT
THE MANDATE ISSUE ON MANDATES
ON.
YOU'RE NOT GIVING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES WHO
SIGNED AN AGREEMENT WAS CMS.
WERE. IN EFFECT WITH THIS IS
BASED ON WHERE YOU'RE GONNA LOSE
NINETY PERCENT OF THE FUNDS WHAT
KIND A SETTLEMENT IS THAT WHEN
YOU LOSE NINETY PERCENT OF THE
FUNDS FOR SCHOOLS. THEY HAVE NO
SKIN IN THIS GAME AND WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IS A SIGNED A
PROPOSAL ON IN FACT THEY MET
WITH THE SCHOOLS COMMUNITY AFTER
THEY SIGNED THE PROPOSAL ON ASK
US FOR OUR INPUT. NOT TELLING US
THAT THIS THING WAS ALREADY
SIGNED ONE OF THE THINGS THEY
GAVE UP WAS THE RIGHT TO APPEAL.
WE LOOKED AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AN APPEALS FROM OTHER
STATES AND WE FOUND AROUND
LOOKING AT TWO THOUSAND APPEALS.
Y. EIGHTEEN OF THEM WHICH WERE
VERY SIMILAR TO THE SITUATION IN
CALIFORNIA YET WE COULD NOT GET
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO FILE AN APPEAL. AS A
RESULT SCHOOL DISTRICTS LOS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS
PART OF THIS IS A PAID BACK AND
WE THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
RECOGNIZE. D. H. CS IS ROLE IN
THIS THERE WAS A RECENT AUDIT
WHICH SAID THAT THEY DIDN'T MEET
THEIR OVERSIGHT ROLE AND WHAT
CMS SAID. ON WHEN THEY DID THIS
DEFERRAL WAS PART OF THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM
THAT I HAD BEEN CREATED WITH
UNCLEAR.
REASONING FROM THE STATE MANUAL
THANK YOU.
CHAIR PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE WANT TO ALIGN OUR
OUR SUPPORT WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF.
ONGOING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION FUNDING THAT GOES
THROUGH CD  I ALSO WANT TO
KEEP OUR EYE TO THE FACT THAT
EDUCATION AGENCIES HAVE USED
THAT INCENTIVE GRANT FUNDING. TO
SCALE UP OUR ABILITY TO MEET THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATOR AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT
MOVING FORWARD THAT THAT FUNDING
IS STILL AVAILABLE SO THAT WE
CAN MEET OUR GOALS ARE TO SCALE
UP THE COLLEGE CREATING THIS
INDICATOR THINK THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TINY CAMERA
TAIWO AND I'M REPRESENTING BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS IN LOS
ANGELES I AM A MIDWIFE AND I'D
LIKE TO.
SPEAK ABOUT THE FUNDING THE
CRITICAL POSITIONS IN THE CD
FOR. ADOLESCENT SEXUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION.
I IF I HAD MORE THAN A MINUTE I
COULD TELL YOU LOTS OF STORIES
ABOUT UMPTEEN PATIENTS WHO HAVE
MADE THEIR WAY TO ME.
NOT REALLY UNDERSTANDING HOW
THEY GOT PREGNANT BECAUSE THEY
WERE TOLD THAT YOU KNOW THEY
COULD. USE COKE AFTER SEX AND
THAT WOULD STOP THE PREGNANCY
OR.
THEY COULDN'T GET A SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE OF THEY WERE
GAY SO THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION THAT'S FLYING
AROUND OUR SCHOOLS. AND.
THIS FUNDING IS PRIMARY
PREVENTION MY WORK IS SECONDARY
PREVENTION
AND MY IT'S MORE COSTLY ON THE
BACK AND OF COURSE AS WE KNOW
AND.
.
THE THE THIS IS A PROVEN PROGRAM
IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS.
FOLLOWING THE ENACTMENT OF ROME
THE SEE YHA THE PERCENTAGE OF
SEXUALLY ACTIVE TEENS.
STUDENTS WHO USE BIRTH CONTROLS
INCREASED AND THE PERCENTAGE OF
STE STUDENTS WHO GAVE ENGAGED IN
SEXUAL ACTIVITY WITH MULTIPLE
PARTNERS DECREASE SIGNIFICANTLY
SO REALLY URGING YOU TO FUND
THESE CRITICAL POSITIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER OF
RICHARD MARX AND ARE REPRESENT A
SIX APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADE OF OR
UNILATERAL A THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE.
EMPHASIS THAT THE GOVERNOR IS.
PUTTING ON THE INCREASED A
SPENDING FOR APPRENTICESHIP BOTH
THE BACKFILL AND HIGHER RSI.
HOWEVER WE WE DO DISAGREE.
WITH THE PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
TWO TIERED A SYSTEM WITH THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
IN FACT SOME OF THE PRESSURE
PROGRAMS.
AND HAVE ARE CHALLENGED I WOULD
SAY.
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES AS THEIR ELLIE A AND I
THINK THIS IS A SET UP A
POTENTIAL CONFLICT WITH THEM.
FOR.
PURPOSES OF DECIDING WHO'S
GOING TO BE THE INSTRUCTOR WHO'S
GOING TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM
A SO WE AGREE WITH THE LA A ON
THAT PROVISION.
IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S A PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND A PRINT SHOP
OPPORTUNITIES A I'M SURE I DON'T
NEED TO REMIND YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT LABOR CODE SECTION
THREE OF SEVEN FIVE. I CAN MAKE
IT A CHALLENGE.
TO CREATE OR EXPAND A NEW
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO I THINK THOSE
GOALS OF EXPANDING THE PRESSURE
OPPORTUNITIES.
PARTICULARLY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES.
MAY BE CONSTRAINED BY THE.
LABOR CODE THANK YOU.
I GET AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I WANTED O KNOW TWO
ITEMS.
FIRST ITEM REGARDING A STRONG
WORK FIRST PROGRAM.
WE APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATIONS THAT APARTMENT A
FEW MEN FINANCE MADE THIS
MORNING TO SPECIFY WHAT IT IS
AND WHAT IS NOT RECOMMENDED TO
BE AT ITS EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
NEVERTHELESS WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE STRUCTURE AND
THAT'S PROPOSED ON HOW THE MONEY
IS. SUPPOSED TO BE I'D UTILIZED
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE SYSTEM
I THINK THAT THERE WERE CREATE
SOME CREATIVE DIFFERENCES THAT
HAPPENED WITH THE IT GUY UNTIL
AT LAST TIME AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
POTENTIAL CREATIVE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN K. TWELVE ON CAN BE
COLLEGE IN THE. FUTURE THE OTHER
ASPECT I DID WANT TO NOTICE WERE
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED TO HAVING
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS USE IN
REGARD TO THE MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT BILLION THAT'S A
MAJOR ISSUE FOR US AND IF WE
WERE TO HAVE TO FUND THIS TO
PROP NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT. A REDUCTION IN THE ONE TIME
FUNDS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
GETTING WE DON'T THINK THAT THIS
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS CAUSED TO
THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM WE DON'T
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR. ARCHER
SIX HAD WORKED IN GOOD FAITH
THEY HADN'T RECEIVED PROPER
GUIDANCE AND SO THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY WERE DOING WHAT WAS
NECESSARY. AND WE DO BELIEVE
THIS NEEDS TO BE SOLVED
SYSTEMICALLY BUT WE DO ENCOURAGE
YOU NOT TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
DENNIS ALL THE ON THE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA GREENFIELD
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SEED
SEVERAL IDENTITIES AND THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE TALKING ON THE CORE
TECHNOLOGY CATION. WE ACTUALLY
THINK THE GOVERNOR WE WANT WE
WANT TO BOTH READ A.
I SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WITH IT WE PROVIDED
HIM WITH SOME LANGUAGE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY WE ALSO SUPPORT
SEVENTY FORTY THREE FRANKLY. A
AND THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE BOTH
DOING THE INCENTIVE GRANT THE
SENATE GRANT HAS BEEN PROVEN.
A WAY TO FUND IT PUTS LOCAL
SKIN IN THE GAME WITH A OF THE
MATCH AND STATE MONEY AND WE
SUPPORT. THAT WHAT WE DO THINK
IS BOTH NEED ACCOUNTABILITY NEED
A LITTLE MORE COUNTABLY SOME OF
THE THINGS ARE DISCUSSED.
ON WHERE THE MONEY GOES. AND
HOW YOU MAKE SURE GETS TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL CAREER TECHNOLOGY
CATION EVEN.
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND SO I THINK
THAT COULD BE FIXED AND AND WE
PROVIDED SOME LANGUAGE AGAIN THE
OTHER.
POLICY BILLS ALSO NEED
ADDITIONAL CAUGHT A
ACCOUNTABILITY WE THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE CLAWBACK AUTHORITY.
WE ALSO THINK THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE.
ANTI SUPPLANT LANGUAGE IN THERE
AND THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE USING
THIS FOR THE SHOULD BE FOR. OUR
EQUIPMENT AND AND THOSE CARS NOT
FOR OF SALARIES SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FOR. FOURTH
YESTERDAY I SPENT.
ONE COMPLEMENT TOM TOWARDS THEM
HE CAME TO THE FAA STAKE
EVENTUALLY SEVEN THOUSAND FUTURE
FARMERS OF AMERICA YESTERDAY.
SPENT ALL DAY THERE.
WITH INDUSTRY FOLKS TRYIN AND
LISTENING TO THEM ON THIS.
CHALLENGE WE HAVE WITH THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM IS ON THE STATE
LEVEL. INDUSTRY ENTITIES ARE
VERY APPREHENSIVE ABOUT GIVING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT TO A
STATE PROGRAM
BUT LOCALLY HIM WITHIN REGIONS
SO THE TECH INDUSTRY. THE AG
INDUSTRY THEY WILL SUPPORT.
LOCAL AND REGIONAL EIGHT OUR
PROGRAMS
SO LET'S AS IT GOES FOR WILL GO
FROM THERE THANK YOU THINK THAT
IS.
HI FRED JONES CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS EDUCATION ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE AUTHOR OF LCF
HALF WAS THE FIRST PERSON IN
THIS BUILDING. TO SET ASIDE
PERMANENT MONEY FOR CAREER TACK
SO WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT.
HAVING SAID THAT I JUST WANNA ME
TO THE COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR OF
THE MISTER O'DONNELL OF MISTER
CHAVEZ MURATSUCHI ABOUT
REGIONALIZATION ABOUT STATE
VISION ABOUT K. TWELVE BEING
BROADER. THAN JUST AND ONLY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU AND THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I THINK STILL
NICOLE RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES A TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE WAS MADE BY THE PRISONER.
IN OUR SUPPORT FOR KRETEK
EDUCATION.
WE TO YOUR GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS.
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE PROGRAMS
NEED TO BE FIND IT PERMANENTLY
BEYOND AND THE SUNSET DATE FOR
THE CURRENT INCENTIVE GRANT BUT
WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT THE EMBEDDING THESE
PROGRAMS INTO THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM IS NOT THE
BEST APPROACH I ALSO WANTED TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
COLLABORATION THE COORDINATION
AND THE ALIGNMENT THAT WAS
DISCUSSED TODAY BETWEEN THE TWO
SYSTEMS. IS CURRENTLY PART OF
THE C. TAKE.
PROGRAM THA IS PART OF THE
ELIGIBILITY IN PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA AS AS WELL AS WELL AS
THE ENGAGEMENT FROM INDUSTRY AND
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY SO ALL OF
THAT IS ALREADY IN THAT.
DOT FORMAT AND WE CAN CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS JUST AS IT
WAS TALKED ABOUT TODAY HOW THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING WITH
THE TWO SYSTEMS MOVING FORWARD.
FINALLY.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT AS A
RELEASE TO THE DISTRICTS HAVE
GONE OUT AND I SEEN THESE
PROGRAMS AS A RECIPIENT FROM THE
MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY AT THESE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR GOOD WORK WE
HAVE SEEN WHAT THEY'RE DOING. SO
I ALSO WANT ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DON'T CHANGE THE RULES
FOR THE DISTRICTS YET AGAIN THAT
SEEMS TO BE HOW WE CONTINUE. OUR
SUPPORT FOR KRETEK EDUCATIONS
EVERY COUPLE OF YEARS WE HAVE A
PROGRAM SUNSET AND THEN THE
RULES CHANGE SO THIS IS WORKING
IT'S A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM WERE
HERE BECAUSE OF THE SUNSET NOT
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
WORK.
AND SO I THINK YOU COMMITTEE CAN
LOOK LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN.
OKAY. WAIT.
YES ULTIMATELY THAT A SEPARATE
ROOM WAITING.
MOSTLY A PRE.
OKAY.
THE OTHER NEXT TO.
KATHLEEN WELCOME